[Music]
[Applause]
this is how we're doing the show from
now
on [__] deal with it and [__] it's
like uh Tool Time his buddy who lived
next
door looking down the barrel of a gun
son of a gun son of a [__] getting paid
getting
rich uh Welcome Friends to another fine
Home
episode of fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Mark Bernard hey how as we say
when we're at the scum and villain
Cantina which were're not tonight sadly
no crowd um but we got a taste of the
scum villain Cantina with us as always
is B man B
man such
excellent my I I'm rebuilt the entire
show from the ground up to use some new
Zoom technology and all of the buttons
are in different places so I'm going to
be a little bit slow that's why we were
late today it was not Kevin and Mark's
fault today it was me look at that look
at him taking the [__] bullets
somebody said before we went I think it
was Anthony Parkinson in chat said um
Madonna's not this late
and we all got scared none of us want to
get sued so started the show even though
we were ill prepared we just [__]
dove into it and now we're here kids
how's everyone we'll do it live yeah fig
[__] out on the Fly um we've got so much
to play with tonight man to talk
about uh to
sell before we do anything we check in
hey how you doing Mark I'm good Kev how
are you so good how you been and B man
oh he took off we should asked him was
like you don't care how I am how you
doing uh I'm good it's been wild um uh
you guys always have top secret projects
to talk about um oh I know you got one
now I do but I can't talk about it for a
few months uh but we talked about it
after um a meeting on your new movie uh
a lot and it's very exciting so this
it's big news uh that he's got and it's
cool and we should all be happy for JC
um once he's able to share it you're all
gonna be like holy [__] can we just end
the show now so he can tell
me shut it down you can can't you mute
it and he could tell you all [__] you
can text it to him right now yeah I okay
I'll text him text otherwise the whole
show is what is it we'll get we'll get a
live reaction Mark we'll see Mark's
reaction and then uh everybody can get
that's good yeah there you go now don't
accidentally say it out loud Mark okay
sucking baby or
something not a second
baby yeah take that off the table kid
you're running for office that's
crazy all right Mark the
uh did got the text we'll see what he's
what's it now I'm eagerly awaiting yeah
we're
all it's it's coming through now Khan oh
excellent
reference oh respect like literally
though it hasn't shown up yet uh it's on
your text your phone text not okay not
the zoom
text
right aren't you happy for our boy B
man boy now is B man [__] yeah man
banana banana stand in chat goes it's a
dickpick can you
imagine like yeah man look at all these
veins Mark was like I've never seen a
more wretched Hive of scum and villainy
uh just because you mentioned all the
veins
um I uh I I'll just talk about it no
we've been doing a lot of um content for
scum and villainy we started a Tik Tok
we've been doing a lot of fun stuff on
Instagram and uh we have a new
nonalcoholic cocktail called the true
blood orange margarita and so I did a
video of how to make the drink kind of
and I used the theme song from True
Blood and and Jen had never seen True
Blood so we've been watching True Blood
and last night this means nothing if you
haven't seen True Blood but we watched
the episode where Suki's brother drinks
the vial of vampire blood and the whole
episode is about his giant painful
erection so
that's what I'm coming what that's how I
went to bed last
night that's how your erection
well watching it on
TV I was like that's how I go to bed
every night
J um what about you mark you've been
going to bed with any painful giant
erections um no no I can buff that out
in about an hour
um uh no I've been I've been working man
I've been writing I've been I've been on
the hustle and the grind as one
does I've been finishing up uh this mace
window book giving some sort of final
coloring notes and things before the
first issue drops on February 7 and we
are doing a signing at Golden Apple in
Los Angeles put up that ad B man the
first of many on screen ads that we're
gonna throw in your face tonight kid
look at that [__] Mark marvelous Mark
Bernard going to Golden Apple right out
here in Los angelis indeed it's a
lunchtime signing you can just skip out
of work for a little bit come on down to
the ga I'll sign up your book that's
smart man 11 to one you lunch time
signings I never knew yeah look at that
[__] Mark Bernard who sits here every
week and periodically we're like why are
you doing this show you're such a good
writer gives away good ideas for free
working in the Star Wars Universe kids
who knew mace Wu book that's kind and
it's it's for for Marvel as well Marvel
and Lucas film baby checking two boxes
right there and nobody so far has has
called me on [__] all over like Boba
Fett or
Ahsoka oh from their organization yeah
are you scared of is the book out yet no
on next Wednesday are you scared of fan
reaction um having lived through Motu
season one with
me you know if you don't get something
right they will let you know there is
nothing they can do to me that hasn't
already been done look at you you're so
[__] seasoned you're like the veteran
of the [__] internet Wars hell yeah I
am [__] over the moon this week
because uh as you well know uh Masters
of the Universe colon Revolution dropped
on
Netflix last last week Thursday night
and to say that I was you know bracing
for you know here comes what I want
through through last time like I I
remember they sent me the trailer the
final trailer and in it there's a
gigantic card that says from Kevin Smith
and I had a serious talk with Rob at
Mattel and Ted at at Netflix to be like
kids I love you you got to take that out
you're just you're gonna make so many
people mad they're not even gonna want
watch this thing and Teddy was like you
know what Kevin you did such a beautiful
job of the story like you're you're
going to I'm giving you your credit
whether you want it or not sweet
sentiment but the whole time I was like
oh no oh oh no so when that trailer went
up there were definitely some people are
like Kevin Smith e [__] it and now I'm
NE definitely not watching so and that
just that you know my entire career I've
had that um to say that like I was
unprepared for the [__] reaction that
we've gotten for this season is an
understatement the it it's a Love Fest
people like absolutely are saying the
nicest things they've ever said about my
work I've right now that Series has 100%
a Rotten Tomatoes like go look at every
other Kevin Smith project see if you can
find one of those and [__] um it's just
it's so lovely like honestly it's so we
opened in the top 10 at number six I
think today we're at like number nine
but it's it's staying alive and [__]
thriving and and the fans are saying
such lovely things uh naturally I love
people who are like hey man I was here
for the last one I'm here for this one
but it feels really good when you hear
from people who were like I did not like
what you did last time I thought you
broke it and boyed you guys fix it and
[__] like stick the landing and like
you know now make more like is is lovely
I I just I can never I have no
idea what the future's ever gonna [__]
hold I really don't I was just prepared
for like well here it comes again it's
going to be like last time and people
are going to be mad at me not at all and
they they saw how much like love and
effort that we put into it
so thank you everybody who's like
watching the show and everyone keeps
asking like is there gonna be more like
that's up to you
kids it literally comes down to there
was only a revolution because
Revelations had the numbers to support
it that was it like it was I've seen
some people be like they started
Revolution when they started Revolution
there was not Revelations was Revelation
was done everything was closed down and
we waited for the show to come out and
then we had to wait the requisite [__]
what is it three months or some such
[__] the algorithm algorithm it works
everything out and then they give you
all the information you've ever you you
couldn't ask for about like how it was
viewed how many many minutes was viewed
how many people finished all the
episodes like it it was crazy and solely
based on that were they like you can go
forward but what they learned from the
algorithm was like I mean this this this
was what they said to us like they break
all the information down they're like
overall you had too many episodes
they're like your show needs to be five
episodes and so our they're like you go
again but it's got to be five episodes
and so we were like all right like
[__] we could do that and honestly
having five episodes forces every choice
to be like this is this got to be
[__] epic worthy because we don't
have that many minutes to play with
there's not that much real estate so
you're you're you know moving the story
along at perhaps a more brisk Pace than
you would like maybe it'd be nice to
have one or two more episodes let it
breathe but we were playing the ball
where it laate and [__] and honestly
because of that I think that helped it
like that made people like the here you
always want to leave people wanting more
and overwhelmingly people are like I
want more when's the next round when
like this is when when is the next
season blah blah blah so in that way us
being forced to like you know all right
tell your story in five episodes instead
of the luxurious 10 that we had last
time and it wasn't even like a a budget
thing it was was just
like I can't even sh I'm not supposed to
share information like this I get in
trouble when but it really came down to
them being like this is what the
algorithm says like it like you would
have got everything would have worked
out better if you were only five
episodes and that was it like our as you
remember Revelation broke in the middle
of a story then told the back end of the
story they were like you can fix
everything by making it five episodes
and I damn it if it didn't turn out to
be accurate you know I'm not gonna say
fixed everything but like it seems to
have that seems to be the what everyone
everyone's like oh this is it was so
fast I want more and it's like better
than you know oh it was long in parts
and I could have done without that so
you know it's been lovely I've never
been on the receiving end of a
mainstream thing that has been received
so well maybe the CW episodes that I
direct and [__] but you know normally I
do Dopey ass Kevin Smith [__] so when
anybody likes it I'm like um this is you
know playing with somebody else's toys
and uh it's been lovely to read people's
[__] reaction but there were there
were many people were like give this guy
a Star Wars and I'm just here to tell
you
no never never in a million years like
give it to Mark Mark Mark's already in
there he's M wind doing it and [__] like
that no
not but I'm I'm so I am very happy with
what we did with Motu because we were
able to
fuse and we did a bit of this in in re
Revelation but a lot more in Revolution
weave in so much lore from so many
different creators like I don't want to
spoil it but it's been out for a minute
but there's a character a main character
played by William Shatner who only came
into existence not from the filmation
run but from the Mike young the
Productions run in 2002 and became a big
part of the Mythos and stuff and so we
got to play with that toy as well and
it's like anybody who steps into a world
where the like all the storytelling has
been going on for years and years you
have the luxury of like not having to do
backstory and when you do do backstory
you can refence reference like the
greatest moments or reference important
moments throughout like the the story
the show's lure or the character's
lore um and and it's you know people it
that's I can't it's 180 degrees from the
last time like and I know there were
people that loved Revelation and they're
still there today going like I was here
for the first one too but it was drowned
out by a bunch of people that did not
like it at all and that doesn't exist
this time around I'm not saying
everybody loves it there's still some
people who who don't go for it but
overwhelmingly it's been such a such a
positive experience the flip side of
like kind
of what what what what I went through
last time and so that it's lovely thank
you to everybody who's watched it and
enjoyed it and you know we we did
it as you can see like a [__] ton of a
attention and care and love and um you
know I get a lot of credit online
everyone's like [__] it Kevin Smith yes
I I believe me I I know how deeply I'm
in there and I know how important I am
to it
but Teddy and Rob like the two the other
two [__] pillars in
peteria
um are I couldn't ask for better
collaborators not only are they my
bosses but Rob has written for the DC
version of Masters of the
Universe and Ted has forgotten more than
most people know he's also the voice of
gildor he was a huge [__] Billy B fan
and he could imitate his voice he winds
up playing guor as well but like you
know people were like oh my God the
[__] accuracy of that one flashback
moment featuring hordak leaving the room
with that bundle and everybody's like is
that the bundle what I think it is of
course that bundle is what but like
they're like oh my God the [__]
shocking accuracy how it plays like
right from the you know the secret of
the sword of the the the
movie um secret the um that kind of
attention to detail comes from a
longtime fan like Teddy poured over
those flashback sequences because as a
big fan of the franchise he's like I'll
tell you what I would [__] love to
see and what would make me lose my mind
so it like my deck was loaded I had two
[__] Titans of Masters of the
Universe lore um who both one is
invested because like you know he's been
he's he's at Mattel for heaven's sakes
and the other's invested because like
this has been
his passion project from the jump we're
only getting to make these cartoons or
the Animated Series because Teddy fought
for it he was just like I he was the one
that was was like honor he's like just
treat him like Shakespeare he's gone you
know I know there's goofy characters in
there but just for once I'd love to see
somebody treat them seriously and that
was always our idea was like you know
it's fun and and [__] there's Wizards
and there's fights and you know [__]
like the deaths are heartbreaking but
not like [__] traumatizing you know
um and into that you can weave like you
can let them let these characters treat
each other seriously and [__] like that
without changing what everyone loves
about it whatnot he just his watch
wordss were like please just treat them
seriously like don't make jokes about
him and [__] like that like it's too
easy treat him like Shakespeare treat it
as if like Shakespeare was right there
and that's why they all talk in like
this very Stenton like [__] you know
I'm on the prum of a
stage type of way but the Gestalt of all
the elements that You' got to throw in
Powerhouse animation and Pat and Adam
our directors who were there with us
last season as well did an astounding
job like people keep giving me credit
for the transformation sequence like
that transformation sequence is [__]
beautiful on episode five like all I
wrote was you know they transformed
together that's it and AD I'm like our
artists and turned it into this
beautiful like Sailor Moon homage that
also is like [__] emotional
underneath poor bear mccreary's genius
score on top of it like there were so
many cooks we had amazing voice cast and
and they all sound wonderful together
and every one of them treated it
seriously none of them came in like what
is this
[__] so it's it's a bunch of people man
and and of course all the work of
everyone who's gone before us the
filmation show the movie which we pulled
into Canon or canonized as they say um
the Mike young series the comic books um
like everything that ever existed um
there are a lot of people online who are
very sweet who are like you did this
with He-Man do it with Thundercats I I
couldn't because I knew the world of
Masters of the Universe I know a lot of
people online have told me that I didn't
but I did literally grow up watching
this cartoon um and it was not I didn't
buy the toys because I was too grown up
by then and admittedly as I've said
before I did a lot of mock watching
where I was like this is ridiculous but
I watched it religiously knew their
mythology and so I got to know even more
once I got the job and [__] where like
suddenly I had access to the sell
archives and since I didn't buy the toys
I never had the mini comics and stuff
like that so it's a rich rich tapestry
but like when somebody's like do do
Thundercats I I I'm not the guy like
somebody I couldn't do Thundercats I
couldn't do um um Transformers like none
of these cartoons I know they exist I
know people love them and they were
around when I was a kid but I did not
interact with them like I like I did
with Masters of the Universe Master of
the Universe I would have collected the
to toys but my parents were like no we
did this with Star Wars we're not doing
a whole other thing because we were not
a wealthy family so I'm so delighted
that people are into the show it it
makes me so [__] happy because again
I I learned on the first season you are
playing with somebody else's toys be
careful and feels like you know second
time up everyone was like some people
are like and some people like now that's
what I'm [__] talking about and some
people feel like hey man this is more of
what you did in the first season keep it
up and stuff
regardless very positive so it's been
Blissful now the big question I get
online is like do you get to go again
when's more coming to go back to what I
said have everything to do with the
algorithm it'll have everything to do
with how many people watch it right
now based on a comparison of the first
go round we are doing better not just
like reception wise critically but we
are in the top 10 longer than we were
with Revelation revelation we were there
for the first day maybe the second but
then disappeared we're still in the top
10 right now so that to me from a Yan's
point of view says that we've started
stronger so that's a really good sign
that we get to to do it again but it
really comes down to how many people
watch it so if you're watching it you're
doing you're manifesting the future kids
if you're like I want more of that
you're just by simply watching it and
I've seen many people social media going
like I've watched this my fifth time
watching it all of that is wonderful and
all helps so thank you Mark some people
have asked Mark was Mark and I said Mark
was Mark was working for Marvel at the
time I was in M yeah he was in M he
couldn't go to to [__] atoria because
he was playing around in wakanda these
are these are rich people problems at
that point I was like Mark can you join
us in Motu and he was like no I'm over
at Marvel now I'm like fair enough my
travel agent had me booked it's like
you're going to wakanda Champ no more
attorney of love for you uh we combine
the two oh if there's a season three if
you if you come back for mass Universe I
don't know reparations then I will be
here for
it there it is everyone's been wondering
what the third one's gonna be and no one
has said reparations
yet uh you had a point I uh it takes
like two years to make the show right
yeah long time not because it's like oh
it's so hard but when you do the writing
like the writing is done like that the
the you know we had designs from season
one but then there of course new designs
for new characters and updates of
characters and stuff but the boys and
and um there's and I believe there was a
third director as
well um couldn't like that's the all the
heavy lifting is theirs like they and it
takes a long time because they got to
design everything then they got to do
the the animatic stage of it that goes
through approvals through you got to
remember a bunch of different people
like it comes to me for approval it
comes to Netflix for approval it comes
to Mattel for approval um I think that's
it so and so there's layers of yes
before it can move forward and stuff so
it's it's not just like drawing takes
time that does but the proc of everyone
going like all right that's it to be
fair that process has always moved fast
on Motu because everyone involved is so
it's not a job where they're like this
just one of 19 things I have to do like
even Teddy who's who's like you know
he's done Wednesday he's done uh [__]
sweet tooth he's done the Avatar
liveaction that's coming like his string
of Netflix shows is is [__] massive
and represents current pop culture
stranger things was his as well so even
though he's got everything else to
manage he's one of the first people
responds when he gets an animatic
because he's watching it as a fan he's
just like oh my God I get to watch a
brand new [__] masters of universe
cartoon and it's you know in its most
nent form pencil sketches but like him
rob me we got back fed as soon as it
comes in we're watching it and [__]
giving any notes now to be fair most of
my notes are literally this holy [__]
that was amazing like that's it I I
really Robin and I'm I'm a terrible boss
in as much as I won't I'm never the guy
that's pushing for more because I'm like
well I can't do that and that's [__]
awesome um Rob and Teddy will always
find a way to be like we can improve
this we can push this up and stuff like
that so if you ask everyone at like
Powerhouse how many notes I've ever
given him on like art and story you know
and like what when I watch the like I'm
the guy when I watch the pencil [__]
animatic I'm like put this on [__]
Netflix now like this is utterly
watchable and they're like please let us
animate it like let us do our thing and
[__] um so yeah they they they those C
to go back to the question JC what was
the question well so I was going to ask
if it takes two years to do the just
animate and get the approvals on the
show is there any way that there's like
an Amo boou of a He-Man Christmas
special while we
wait I I look I never say never but I
just don't see how the timing of that
would work like because the moment that
first off we'd have to get that
approved and that they'd probably be
like well we have to wait for the
algorithm to come back for revolution so
we'd be waiting anyway but then we'd be
adding work to work the idea would be in
the next season to Christmas it
we we haven't really picked a season
before but it could take place at
Christmas time and if you've watched
Revolution to the end to The Bitter End
you kind of like see the direction that
were headed
and Christmas family like these are
things that like would
be at home where going in the future and
that's all I could [__] say but you
honestly it doesn't take a [__]
soothsayer to see where we're going by
the end of the [__] episode in our
post credit sequences we [__]
Telegraph where we're going and it is
very very badass it's it's very cool so
fingers crossed that we get to do it
again but honestly if the algorithm came
back and was like nah no not enough
people watch it we're not going to do it
again I could never complain because the
love that we've received for this season
alone was like worth the trip um and and
to have to have people be like oh my God
[__] like you you gave me the thing
that the version of this that I've been
waiting for my whole life like all that
[__] is so gratifying that even if we
didn't get to go again I'd be like it
doesn't matter we did it and people dug
it and blah blah blah but I honestly
like knock wood right now things look
very positive
yeah I mean a Christmas special would be
awesome but you would have had to have
like we're doing six instead of five and
one of them is a special that we will
drop six months after that's just like I
have such vivid memories of watching
that the the OG one like when I was like
God I made five or six years old I
remember that so well it was so
exciting somebody in chat said uh so
some contracts are signed allowing that
to happen
no there's like nobody's there's no
contracts in place or I mean you know
there's contracts and as much as like
people who've
returned if if we were having people
return like we did with season
two I'm sure there's some exist I don't
see that [__] that's above my paperwork
but they don't it's not like we're all
contracted like we weren't contracted
for season two with season one so when
season one ended that was it we had to
wait for it to come on when it came on
we had to wait for the [__] algorithm
so once the algorithm came through and
said yeah you can go again and it'll be
five episodes we were like great we had
to get the whole [__] team back
together they were off doing like the
boys and and Powerhouse went off to do
more Castlevania or [__] they do that
Greek god show or something and um you
know I was off doing [__] clerks 3
and and other things and and then when
they were like okay we are going to go
again everyone had to pull back to
together so same thing here like we're
done and like the writers have been done
forever uh the voice acting has been
recorded a long time ago um you know and
I can't remember the last time we even
did pickups on it um which that was like
six months ago so it's been put to bed
for a while for everybody but the
animators like you know the PowerHouse
crew works until I think they you know
delivered a few days before it
went live on Netflix because I know you
know
what yeah I shouldn't we had we had to
we had a last
minute
we I'm not you know I'm just gonna stop
I don't want to I don't want to lose
this [__] job let it go yeah it's
it's inside baseball and stuff but
there yep
yeah anyway it was it was done pretty
fairly recently the because like the
animation kids take so long it's so it's
just like you know bear [__] recorded
his
score I guess he locked before we
started the 430 movie he was already
done and you know he composes and then
granted he got to reuse a lot of the
themes that he created for Revelation
but he created new themes he had to
create a theme for hak and [__] like
that and he also plays the scenes so
he'll compose to the scenes so he put in
a whole new round of music and then you
know he'll he composes it at home and
then he conducts it with an
orchestra um where he's on zoom and he
has a full [__] like 100 piece
Orchestra that's why those things sound
so [__] powerful in frog or whatever
is that where budapes I want to
say um but he's been working with them
for so long now he's like when I first
started working with him because he uses
them for like he does you know bear of
course does um Lord of the Rings on
Amazon Walking Dead But the orchestral
stuff he
does um he tends to go big Orchestra
with that the Budapest Group which now
knows him and he knows them very well
and their their is astounding but yeah
it's I'm sorry I'm probably talking
about [__] Motu way too much
um but I'm just so nice to not have to
be like yeah Motu moving
on giddy like a school girl oh good lord
um we have we found a few shirts because
when we did Motu Revelations revelation
we did re a revelation celebration at
Jane s Bob secret stash B man throw up
that
t-shirt this is by Captain ribman it is
Jay and S Bob as he man and
Skeletor um and that was the shirt that
we gave out when we we did that uh uh
Masters of the Universe uh Revelation
celebration um we just found like a
[__] bunch of them in the warehouse
so put them up on sale earlier today if
you go to job.com you get one of them
sweet shirts kids for their while
supplies last I believe there's only 40
left there you
go
um okay that's the last thing I'll say
about Motu
tonight um should we do should we do an
ad before we get into the the rest of
the the fun times yeah we should because
kids we're so lucky
tonight uh we got a brand new sponsor
man please welcome to the show The Good
Folks at
tushy
tushy how cute is that hello
tushy um over three million butts love
tushy kids get 10% off tushy with the
code fat man at
HTTP hello tushi.com
Fatman hash tushy pod and now you're
sitting there going what is tushy it's
exactly what you're probably thinking it
is are you tushy let's see what they
call
it
tushy tushy is a [__] it's a it's an
ass douche right it's a Beday as the
French call it absolutely
um I know this because even before they
joined us as sponsors my kid when she
still lived here and her boyfriend
during the pandemic they got a tushi and
applied it to their toilet and so during
the pandemic I would sneak down to her
bathroom when they weren't around and
use the [__] tushi because it was so
good this kids you know you wipe your
ass wipe your ass with toilet paper and
[__] and we all know you can dig and dig
and dig but very rarely do you get every
[__] piece which means that you're
sitting around with a [__] crack full
of bacteria and whatnot and then you
could go with wet wipes but oh God that
creates a [__] fat BG in the [__]
sewer system and [__] like that how else
to clean that filthy little [__] of
yours do you have a filthy little
[__] well guess what tushy gonna help
out man you sit down on this thing and
you turn the dial when you're done
little [__] bar comes out sprays jet
sprays water straight up your [__]
man just water picks all the [__] out
every nook and cranny man you want to
test it take a Thomas English muffin put
butter on it and then [__] take tushy
and fck spray it back and forth watch
all that butter every nook and cranny
gets clean because tushy knows how to
clean the [__] man tushy I'm telling
you we all Giggle and [__] but poo poo
is a part of our lives and whatnot for a
limited time our listeners are going to
get 10% off their entire order at
hellotushy.com go to H
T y.com and use the code fat man for 10%
off man it's time to get rid of those
skid marks once and for all my friends
Mark you got any experience with the
tushy like I do I mean listen I I I
thought you might have needed like an
age gate for a tushy because it sounds
intimate it's it sounds like you're
going for it but hey man like it's it's
it stays clean and hygienic with its
patented selfcleaning smart spray the
nozzle self cleans before and after each
use automatically the buildup resistant
design helps to minimize Grime buildup
and even has ACT antimicrobial knobs
which also sounds dirty the Beday stays
clean just like your booty every tissue
bday comes with a 30-day hassle-free
return and a 12-month warranty it's
risk-free to join over 3 million real
pooping humans who have made the switch
to a cleaner and more confident butt I'm
I'm all for talking more about this you
know on oh [__] I don't want to talk
about [__] and [__] it's time look
the more we talk about [__] the more
we confront the [__] the better life
will be and [__] and the first [__]
you ever got to confront is your goddamn
own start in your own backyard and [__]
literally in your own backyard and what
not keep that [__] clean as a whistle
you could do it with tush you don't even
have to touch it yourself no more
[__] like oh my fingers went through
the toilet paper and [__] like that TI
she just sand blasts your [__] clean
man in the most Pleasant way
these pipes are clean oh yeah [__]
when a tush is done as it pulls back in
you hear the voice of the lady from
polter guys going this ass is
clean voice not guaranteed as a partner
no what are you waiting for man [__]
toilet paper is bad for the environment
with tushy use 75% less toilet paper um
the whole bedet stays clean and [__]
with its patented selfcleaning smart
spray um and it comes with a 30-day
hasslefree return turn and 12month
warranty so you can use this [__] for a
month literally clean your [__] for a
month and be like I don't want it
anymore and you'll send it back and
they'll be like we'll take it thank you
thanks for trying it's got 12- month
warranty man it's risk-free join over
three million real pooping humans as
Mark said who've made the switch to a
cleaner more confident [__] butt get
the fresh out of the shower feeling at
hello
tushi.com fun to say for a limited time
our listeners get 10% off your entire
order when you use the code fat man all
one word at checkout that's 10% off your
order at h l l t
uy.com with the promo code fat man it's
time to back that ass up with confidence
not a line that I wrote they wrote I
appreciate their copy is naughty they're
like look you know what our business is
[__] so we're gonna be frank about
it look at woman why don't you back that
ass up say you look good would you back
that ass up we uh thank the good Folks
at tushy for [__] sponsoring this
episode of uh fat man beyond we hear it
at fat man beyond we co-sign a clean
[__] we'll literally do it for you if
you spread your cheeks you come to the
live show and speaking of live
shows nice uh B man throw up that piece
of artwork
advertising a very special event at SM
Castle Cinemas in New Jersey based
around Mark Bernardin oh my God held out
as long as there it is kids the eyeses
of Mark have returned man uh what's the
date we're doing it uh March 15 and 16th
the legit Ides the legit Ides uh it
starts off with a double feature on
Friday night man that's uh fat man
beyond Fatman beond live it'll be
streamed you can watch it on the
internet and whatnot and then afterwards
we're having a secret
screening can't say what it is but look
at that
artwork we can't say what it is but dig
if you will a picture oh yes we can't
say what it is kids but you come to
modcast on on [__] March 15 Let's Go
Crazy let's get
nuts you want to get nuts no not it's
although there a tangential Connection
in a weird way um anyway on March 15th
we're doing fat man Beyond at night and
we're following fat man beyond
immediately with a free secret screening
yes very cool Friday Night movie that
everyone's
gonna it'll make people as happy as if
they were masturbating with a
magazine that's right the odds of Mark
and then the next day on March 16th
we're going to do uh two more movies man
Mark is showing at 12:30 blade yep the
OG doomsday doomsday and if you've never
seen doomsday you owe it to yourself to
see doomsday because doomsday is a
different movie every 20 minutes and
every one of those movies is a movie
that you love it's like oh do I love 28
Days Later excellent it's here do I love
escape from New York excellent we got
there do I love the road warrior fizel
do I love Excalibur absolutely and so
you can just take a [__] daisy chain
tour through genre Confections all in
the same
movie so much fun fun fun pair of days
kids come Friday night March 15th
Saturday March
16th we're celebrating the eyes of Mark
man come see us do fat man Beyond at SM
Castle Cinemas one of our greatest shows
we ever did I think was like the last
time we did it at span Castle Cinemas
great VI great crowd come on out and
join us tickets right now at smodcastle
cinemas.com or
cmod uhcom and what before we dive into
the news what are the other things JC I
sent JC you got the the
Bendy oh yeah throw up that major bendy
man sounds like I got like something
like an old time of disease like you got
the chingles you got the bendy's you've
been diving too much the uh major
wrestling uh podcast uh is doing these
major bendies of Jay and Silent Bob man
so you can have Jay and Silent Bob
fighting [__] sergeant
um and and and Sergeant Slaughter
beating both of us pinning both of us if
you will uh throwing us outside of the
Ring they're like the old wrestling
bendy man they look like that so they
they're doing custom order um you can
order up to February 5th man go to Major
bendy.com uh to get those uh Hey Cruz of
skew is coming up 25 26 days from now
man 24 days yeah what is it 24 days wow
24 days man join us on the high seas uh
it's me it's Jay it's Mark Bernardin
it's Ralph
Garmin it's uh Andy melrish it's Brian
o' hallerin it's Jeff Anderson it's
Jason Lee
it's Ethan SLE it's uh oh [__] the list
goes on man Trevor Ferman lias is going
to be there Jennifer schwabach Smith um
it's good times kids this is our first
cruise man we're going to read the clerk
the the original Clerk's 3 script the
really sad one and you're like there was
a sadder version of clerk 3 oh yeah I
was going through some [__] and uh then
we're gonna read the M rats 2 script you
know it's gonna be a good ass time um
Ming was just on the Impractical Jokers
cruise with Brian Quinn our friend Brian
Quinn and and uh we were doing it with
the same company Sixth Man uh and Ming
was like oh my God it was so much fun
you guys are going to have a blast so
ming I think might be coming on our
cruise as well but uh that's happening
soon tickets kids uh at Cru
escue uh.com if you want to join us man
uh then uh let's see what else we got oh
this weekend Thursday yeah look at this
never mind this weekend we'll do that we
made a huge announcement yesterday
chronicon kids there's actually gonna be
a real life chronicon man thanks to the
good Folks at astronomicon who we met
when we did the astronomicon show back
in June they were like why don't you
have your own con and I was like what
what do you mean they're likewhy don't
you have kevc con like [__] it makes
no sense I was like well kevc con seems
a little [__] arrogant but like if
you're telling me that you would like to
do a real life chronicon like you know I
being able to make [__] from my stupid
ass movies come true in real life oh my
God like what a and we built chronicon
so it's happening in October it's gonna
be in Chicago Illinois some people are
like why not jersey Chicago is easier
for both coasts to get to also we have a
very nice Illinois fan base thank the
Lord um but also we're doing it at a
place it's very sentimental favorite to
us we went to the Wizard World
convention at the Rosemont Hyatt Regency
for years me and Jay so when we were
talking with the astronomicon kids about
where to go you know they're like yes of
course starting a jersey makes sense but
like you have the theater there like it
feels like we're going to try this let's
try it out in a market that's not
necessarily geared to let's try Chicago
and I was like can we do it at the high
Regency where we went to the [__]
wizard world every year and [__] The
Beatles commom was happening at the same
time and [__] and so that's where we're
having it so it's a Sentimental favorite
to us it's the G we haven't announced
anybody but me and Jay but like the
guest list is [__] nuts we're
celebrating both the 30th anniversary of
Clerks and Tusk as well so and plus a
bunch of other things but it's basically
going to be like the crew's been on land
um three days in Chicago well out on the
outskirt of Chicago you flying oir that
[__] hotel is like five minutes down
the road man it's G to be a good ass
time and if it works then we'll take it
to the West Coast to the east coast and
everywhere else man chronicon straight
from the from the frames digital frames
of Jay and Silent Bob reboot chronicon
happening in real ass life tickets go uh
tickets at chronicon for
real.com f for Real uh and then this
weekend uh or this rather this week
Thursday and
Friday I'm GNA be on the radio again
last week I took over for Gary and
Shannon they were off on Thursday and
Friday KFI AM uh
640 uh in Los Angeles but everywhere on
the iHeart Radio App and um so they're
gone again this week and they asked hey
man you want to come in take over again
[__] [__] yeah somebody asked me like
why are you doing this and I was like
because I I don't live far and I love
the sound in my own voice so
those the only two qualifications that I
need to be asked to do a thing and I
didn't if you for a thing somebody asked
aren't you getting paid I'm like no
should I I never even thought ask about
money I thought it was cool that they
let me take over the radio for a day I
mean it is AM radio like if there was
money in AM radio there'd be lots more
people doing AM radio there's money in
AM radio and I'm gonna find it I'm gonna
find it share it with you one day you're
going to be sitting there going like I
can't believe we got rich at AM radio
yes because nobody else was here it's
dude everyone went to podcasting I went
to podcasting in 2007 now the whole
[__] world isn't podcasting everyone
abandoned radio Now's the Time to run
back take over nobody's
there they left the lights on the mics
are on [__] go they didn't even lock
the doors they didn't even think anybody
would want it exactly FM maybe they
locked one of their doors he left the
doors wide open I went in and hung out
and it was a blast dude because I've
always loved radio and I was like holy
[__] like this is the life would have
been [__] amazing for me I'm like
doing film is like telling any visual
story for me it's not my first language
like it's almost like learning Spanish
taking High School Spanish and then
trying to go to Spain and pass you know
as somebody who's fluent and [__] like
but talking like this [__] oh God that's
I've been doing that since like [__]
I started talking my whole life that I
could do without [__] it up
relatively speaking so I you know I I've
been having fun with it I'll go back
anytime they ask me but don't you
[__] po poo AM radio
money there's gold in them in the AM
radio Hills I I promise you there's
always money in the AM radio stand
yes someone in sinful hands in chat says
I'm here because of AM radio there you
go we did an informal poll at Babylon
the other night we did a Babylon show if
you want to watch it it's right here on
youtube.com kevinsmith but on Saturday
night we did Babylon at Flappers and um
there was well I was there I was like
hey man [__] like because we on the
Monday of that week the Monday before
that Friday we were at only 86 tickets
sold and then by Saturday Showtime we
were sold out so and we sold out the
night before so I was like that has to
be me sitting on AM radio KF talking
about hey man [__] we're doing a show
right down the street I kept throwing to
it every hour so in the room I was like
hey man just want to do an informal poll
how many people are here tonight because
they heard me on KFI AM literally three
people clapped out of 200 like do I have
a radio in my car it was it was crazy
embarrassing I was I really thought that
I'd [__] cracked the code and [__]
and Ralph was like how many people here
because the Ralph report the whole
[__] a winds up applauding and I was
like well never mind perhaps it's
perhaps AM radio doesn't have as much
reach as I thought it did but I'm still
happy to sit in and do it did anybody
here get my
telegram oh I sent one to everyone
please come
but I've I've had a good time doing so
yeah kids Thursday and Friday you can
listen if you got an iHeart Radio App
you don't even have to be in Los Angeles
I asked them I was like who listens to
AM radio to like a shocking amount of
people and I was like what like in their
cars and they're like well yeah some
people listen in their cars while
they're driving but uh she was like
we're on the iHeart rap and KFI iHeart
app and KFI is really like high up there
like either number three or sometimes
number one wow I was likewhat why and
she's like this is Los Angeles like talk
radio in Los Angeles one of the biggest
cities in the world I'm like yeah I
guess that I guess that makes sense just
never thought about it before so it's
also always on in nursing homes like
that's the station that they just leave
on who do you think I'm trying to Jane
Silent Bob fan bucking Mark like I lost
the youth now I'm going for the elderly
and [__] who loves cruises senior
citizens exactly now you see now you're
getting it
you know who you know you know who's
comfortable in this world not worrying
about paying bills and [__]
seniors Security checks man they gotta
be entertained it's me or [__] you
know uh It's Not Unusual to be loved by
anyone if Alonso
rera um yeah man is I look I'll take I
don't give a [__] here's the thing
here's the here's the upside of maybe it
is maybe it is an old audience Mark May
it is in on on on nursing homes and [__]
like that here's the good news none of
those people have heard all my jokes or
material for so I got 30 years where the
clerk's jokes B rat's jokes Chase G
jokes that I could pull out parade for
this brand new audience and they'll be
like oh he's such a Charming young
man I mean listen I've gotten my first
ARP emails like the minute I think you
hit the the
when once that clicks over Sly like hey
man you want some insurance hey man you
want I look I refuse I refuse to accept
my old age adolescent till I die but
I'll tell you right now I feel like am
and maybe I'm just trying to Manifest
this but I feel like am is a little more
punk rock than FM
radio AM radio is the dude who rolls up
on the Starbucks and pulls out his Smith
Corona and sets it on the table and
starts hammering away at his keyboard
who don't love that [__] guy Mark
everyone loves that
guy he's my
favorite oh good
God EXC two men Thursday what are you
doing Thursday or Friday you want to
come in on the radio uh in the mornings
what when is when is the signing of
golden apple next Wednesday [__]
doesn't matter come in this Thursday or
Friday I'll hook you up with mon the
producer and [__] come and promote if
you're in town I don't want to pressure
you into something you could also when
does Splinter go wide let's talk about
Splinter goes Wi on Friday we flip it
live to the internet bro I can introduce
you to the of AM
radio do you know who reads you know who
reads mace Wu Comics people in Senior
Communities that's who buys ma wind it's
a Jedi for me
but you should you should tell me what
day when we're done Thursday or Friday
roll up man you could even call him but
rolling up makes you feel [__] cool
and it's right around the corner from
your house it's it's you know where it
is you know where the Whole Foods is in
the valley yeah like in burck right next
door to Warner Brothers okay that's
where it is where we want to strike and
[__] um it's in that plaza where the
Morton is yes that I know all right so
[__] it you you come on you'll
legitimize that [__] you can talk about
mace Wu you can [__] sell make sure
you restock the um what's the
T-shirt oh I don't even know if they
have it for sale anymore softly but let
[__] know what is
it be humble but let [__]
know yeah come on dude come on the show
JC hey B
man B so last time I was on
we had the um woman who created and runs
sugar Taco because they love doing like
a you know [__] local business person
SE segment we gotta do [__] scum and
villainy man I'll come on I get up early
I got a
kid you know what I'm saying this is
this is this is why this radio thing
makes so much sense for me I don't have
to do the work I bring in a friend bring
in another friend I'm like talk about
[__] I just love that you're you're
recycling the Kevin Smith business plan
for a different medium you see so
[__] clearly my friend all that
podcasting that since 2007 was just
dress rehearsal for our futures an AM
radio oh the power of amplitude
modulation exactly same place you go for
Hurricane
news weather traffic that's where we
going to find this little [__] face
right here is there an earthquake
happening no Kevin Smith's on the air
that's
right uh oh Congo kids club is saying
this is not good we should move on from
this subject oh no this is great I I am
hubly rebuked he's tired of hearing us
talk about old man
am time to talk about something new and
[__] welcome to my
newsletter yeah which is like a pamphlet
I'm handing it at the mall but it's an
email instead um what uh what news do we
have um even before we do the
news um I've seen some [__] in the
world uh are you up to date on True
Detective night country I have watched
all three episodes of True Detective
colon the
thing uh how are you feeling about two
detective [__] the
thing um there's only four episodes left
so they better get
cracking um it somebody said that
they're tying it in with the first
season of the OG True Detective I mean I
think the whole like the spiral squirly
thing right that was yeah the symbol of
carcosa I think is what it was and and
you know it's it's apparently they're
telling either a scientific or a
Supernatural story or a scientific
Supernatural story um you know I got a I
got Max I got HBO I'm already paying for
it so it's no skin off my ass and is
wellmade um and I'll watch Jody or do
anything and who's the other lady she's
fantastic uh Callie Reese I think her
name is I think this is her first ever
thing wonderful um I'm also interested
in like like I don't want people to be
like what how can you compare this to
Miss Marvel but it's a look into a
culture that I had never looked into or
seen into
before like remember Miss Marvel we were
like holy [__] man [__] who knew like
we literally went into another cultural
world uh same thing here like I you know
you're you're in in the midst of them
telling a story they're taking you into
a completely different world that I've
not seen represented in movie after
movie after movie and so on that level
it's really interesting and it's also
cool to see them casting a bunch of
veritable unknowns like who are
authentic to
the um you
know some [__] is the body tangle
totally calls to mind the thing but
these cats weren't all [__] one fused
together they're just all Frozen
together and slowly Tha out um
horrifying moment I think at at the was
it the end of one or in one when [__]
the dude wakes up he's like yeah yeah I
think that's it's either one or two that
suddenly he starts screaming yeah that
[__] me up hardcore and then they go
back to him in episode three and he's in
the hospital and he has a [__] moment
where spoil I mean spoilers if you
haven't seen any of the before cuz we're
going to go I mean we're obviously
talking about details here but there's a
moment where he does something
Supernatural before he goes back to just
this hor horrifying screaming man like
who's lost limbs and [__] is I guess
his eyes he tried to claw out and
[__] it's that that was horrifying
we're just like holy [__] but he's got
that like Father Caris moment yeah yes
that's what that's a great great
reference yeah which is it is [__]
horrifying um I kind of I think they're
doing a good job being scary I mean look
the it's definitely scarier than season
two except how season two was like it's
scary how this is not season
one um and three I feel I feel like it's
scarier than that there's more
opportunity for Horror in the in the the
40 Days of Night world that they're
telling the story plus you start adding
stuff like she's awake and and [__]
ghosts walking in the in the in the
darkness like you know it's it's it it
does it's un it's it's doing a good job
scaring yeah I mean it's it's it's all
unsettling right like unnerving un yeah
the the the atmosphere given that yeah
the Sun never Rises um for 30 40 days
whatever that is is like from the jump
disorienting like there's people talking
about having pancakes and it's dark out
and people talking about like oh it's
lunchtime and it's dark out like it's
just always dark and that like removing
that level of temporal awareness is is
kind of freaky um the murder crime
murder stuff is like all right clue tra
I get it I understand it but for me it's
working on this level of bring me into a
world that I don't know which is namely
like [__] out in the middle of
nowhere Alaska plus indigenous alaskans
plus um you know like a mining town on
the edge of the world like it's all just
very very interesting and dense and the
director Issa Lopez is doing a wonderful
job of just like hitting you with these
images that show you how weird and
wonderful this kind of world is and yeah
I'm [__] here for jod foster man like
I just it's it's kind of easy to forget
because she doesn't work that often um
just how [__] great she is talking
about somebody who's been working since
she was what seven eight years old and
you could like this is a lifer who knows
how to ju even do something as simple as
put groceries away on camera make it
look believable and natural like they're
just a different breed aart the actors
especially ones who've been doing it for
decades because they make natural such
insanely natural choices that it would
never occur to me to even ask for in a
scene or if I was in the scene do myself
and she's one of those people where it's
just like she's forgotten more about the
craft than most people will ever [__]
know because she's been doing it since
she was a kid you want to talk about
10,000 hours of practice never mind the
fact that she has a [__] Academy
Award she's just one of the greats man
big year for her that and and NAD as
well right yeah you know and and I
remember I I was listening to an
interview with with Issa Lopez the
writer director showrunner who said that
you know the dream of all dreams was to
get jod Foster and then jod read the
script and wanted to have a meeting and
at that meeting jod was like I really
want to play an ask hole can you make
Danvers more of an [__] like no
redeeming qualities she's prickly to
everybody she meets she lies all the
time like she's an unreliable narrator
like just go [__] hard and and and
the director was like torn between her
desire for it to be Clarice Starling
because I think that's everybody's kind
of desire and just make her an
unrecognizably unrepentant douchebag and
the fact that that's what jod wanted to
do was fascinating and she's leaning
into it I don't know if Hank well Hank
Hills says in chat the ghost walking in
the darkness that led the old lady to
the
bodies who is called Travis Cole that's
the name she keeps talking about Travis
took me there Travis Cole is the father
of rust
Cole Matthew mcc's character from True
Detective season
1 yeah I mean I think in season one
MCC like rust does say that his dad
lives in Alaska or something to that
effect um and Hank Hills [__] just
also fed as a big I didn't I didn't I
never made that connection never would
didn't remember that far back I didn't
either like I also saw that somebody was
connecting these dots on the internet
because like not to say it's easy to do
but when there's opportunities to be
like how can we connect these two worlds
and make it feel like a coherent thing
just like yeah all right we're going to
have this old man character you all
right JC yeah JC we keep hearing you are
you jerking off I think we heard you
come
weird did are you in the my mic is not
on so why are you hearing me we heard
you you were
like yeah I was like look we all like
True
Detective I was clear in my throat oh
interesting okay well good to know
um yeah it's it's totally good watch man
where do you think it's going more
scientific or more scii or more
Supernatural um it it it seems like this
is a world in which like the
supernatural exists to people you know
that this is a thin spot between
realities between the afterlife and and
the current life I think it's one of
those shows where there will be a
scientific explanation like these guys
drilling into the core of the earth into
the deep ice flows looking for ways to
stop death you know could release some
ancient [__] biohazard right like
some Spore of a plant that's been
extinct for a billion years and that's
what's making people do weird [__]
that's what's making people see weird
[__] that's what's making people it's
affecting them in a neurotoxin kind of
way and so they're scared and they run
out into the co all of that [__] could
be a scientific explanation or go ahead
or yeah it's [__] ghosts you know
it's the dead is coming back to haunt
skate Alex to in chat has an interesting
take it might also be mental delusion
apparently the water is toxic which they
have been telling us in the background
of the
story and so maybe it's that maybe they
all got [__] poisoned by this [__]
horrible water and you see jod fall you
see Danver go to wash her hands and
suddenly all the water is like gray and
Inky because the the mine is [__] with
everything
um but yeah no I dig it I'm I'm I'm on
board I'm here for it um I also saw and
I mentioned this to you earlier today uh
this new documentary on Netflix called
the greatest night in pop because you
said that I watched it what did you
think of it fantastic Netflix I mean two
for two in terms of the random music
documentaries that I clicked on like
couple months ago I clicked on the Wham
documentary one night so good
unbelievably [__] good where I'm like
holy [__] man like not only do I know
literally every song but like this is
great like footage of them at their Peak
and they they both seemed to really like
each other and there was no like [__]
like bitter War just like it and he one
encouraged the other to grow as a music
uh producer and and you know not just a
songwriter but making music without wh
like it it was fantastic so that was the
last music documentary I watched on
Netflix High bar this thing matched it
in terms of like holy [__] look at this
footage look at all this [__] behind
the scenes footage from something that
we've seen our entire lives over and
over again but it's almost as if
somebody moved the camera this way and
you got to see the rest of the picture
so you're seeing like all the backstage
stuff you see wh and dens leave like I
ain't singing to no Swahili and he just
bounces and you see a current day um
Sheila E talk about like feeling like
they were just kind of using me to get
to Prince so that stuff was
heartbreaking man that really broke my
heart man I was like oh my God because I
was always happy to see Sheila E in the
chorus of We are the world I mean I was
massive and we still remain a massive
Sheila E fan but um she to hear her say
like that she felt that way and then
left I mean you know at the same time
not everyone got a solo and stuff but
she did say at the end she was like look
I'm honored to be involved
um the
uh
watching Michael
Jackson do stuff that I've never seen
him do on camera
before in as much as like create a song
well you know right there of course open
for all sorts of inter interpretation
there's a lot of things I ever saw
Michael Jackson do on camera before um
compose a song like just by and and it
was interesting as [__] lion Richie was
like he couldn't play any instruments so
for him it was all
like and he would sing every musical
part but lion Richie I could see why
lion o Richie was like can we please
make this documentary because
essentially this documentary about the
busiest day that lion o Richie ever had
life you could make a whole fiction
narrative a whole movie about this one
day where he is essentially hosting the
American Music Awards at which he sweeps
and wins a bunch of awards himself and
when the show is over he literally goes
down the street from my [__] house to
right across the street where we used to
have an office what used to be the
chaplain Studios and then was A&M
records back in the day I've always
known it as the Henson Studios I don't
know know what it is now but we had
still is is it still hon we had one of
the Bungalows there at one point I had
no idea that's where they [__]
recorded We are the world and [__] and
he had he got them all together over the
course of a night until like 5 six in
the morning and recorded that [__]
song while they're recording the song
they're also shooting that music video
which we all [__] saw it mind-bending
how busy that dude was that day and he
got it all done that I could I could see
that guy going can somebody please make
a documentary
about like I gu We are the world
happened but it like a lot happened that
day it was and then watching all the
Quincy Jones stuff and the huie Lewis
stuff I think was my favorite because
huy always felt like he just like why is
he here huie was all of us we saw huie
Lewis in We are the world we were like
they're there am I like that's who I
would be at that place like yeah I can't
the only other avatar for the normal
person is Dan akroy who's also [__]
there and you're like which I thought
about and for the first time today
understood Dan akroy was a a gold record
multi-platinum record or multipl
whatever the highest [__] record
sales you could get for The Blues
Brothers so he wasn't there like I'm Dan
akroy he's half of the [__] Blues
Brothers and it wasn't that long after
we'd lost Belushi or I think maybe two
years after BL she died but that makes
sense that never like I was never
against it but I was like oh I guess Dan
Arro wasn't busy that day of course they
would have him he was [__] like a
literally a bankable music star so I
think I mean kind yes brothers were huge
huge they were huge but nobody could be
like you know what man bl's Brothers
they wrote so many great original songs
they they they they went on to a long in
history you know it's like there's
Springsteen and then there's the blues
true true but let's be fair LaToya
Jackson was also there I mean I think
like she and reeby and whoever else
showed up were just like driving
michaelo was there as well you know
what's really weird is that Latoya is
there but Janet's not and one year later
you couldn't you couldn't miss Janet
Jackson because that's
when control drops and she becomes huge
as big as her [__] brother almost
gets to be as big as Michael um there
there's that great like the wide shot of
the entire like the the chorus of
everybody and Michael's over here and
the rest of his is all the way over
there yeah but the the craziest thing
was like every now and again like we all
know that song so [__] well even if
we haven't heard it in like 25 years
like we know it and so every now again
in that documentary you would encounter
the version of a lyric that's in the
song right it's like the Cindy loer
stuff like she's like doing three or
four test runs of it and then she does
the [__] thing and you're like there
it is that's the one that made the cut
that's the one that's in the song and
it's just it's kind of insane it's kind
of I was doing that too spot the moment
where it's like oh there's the real
reading of that line yeah yeah about
[__] poor Huey walk Singh in chat
says We Are the World idea was taken
from feed the world that Bob gelof did
first in the UK yeah they talk about
that in the documentary they have Bob
gof there Bob comes in and tells them
you know we did this right and then
gives him a very rousing speech and [__]
yeah they don't hide that there's
there's nothing you know there's not a
lot of warts here like that was the one
thing like Jen and I were watching it
and and uh we were talking about you
know it's 1985 it's some of the biggest
music stars in the world how much coke
is in that room it's two in the morning
they're still
recording like yeah like aljo is the
only one who's a little inebriated like
I thought that little that that was a
little scandalous that they really threw
jro under the bus where they're like
well he was he was celebrating before we
even [__] finish the song and ju
coming in and going
out but what are the CH like that was
the one thing I was like you know
nobody's going to talk about like they
were doing anybody doing drugs not like
it would have mattered but it's like how
the [__] is everyone still awake 4 5 in
the morning U Bob gelof speech certainly
helps because he really he really
galvanized
everyone you guys all these children are
dying now you have to sing a song and
like Stevie wants to do it in African
like no Stevie how adorable was he
though like he's great Stevie Wonder was
was like playful and [__] puckish and
there's something he did oh where he
sang for Bob Dylan as Bob Dylan and they
were like Stevie is an excellent mimic
so he sang in Dylan's voice to Dylan to
show him what to do in the song so he
was like it's true Mega birthday it's
you [__] Stevie Wonder singing like
almost like making fun of Bob Dylan Like
This is what you sound like it's you a
bet and Bob was like I get it and went
and [__] sang it that [__] like holy
[__] I really felt like I was a fly on
the wall for some magic there and also
Stevie Wonder walking Ray Charles to the
bathroom I know the way that was
hysterical yeah somebody was like
somebody literally said out loud that is
literally the blinding the
block and when they were singing oh you
know it was really heartwarming when
like Harry bellafonte they were done
with the chorus and he was gonna leave
and they and they shouted him out there
like Harry Bellon and then what seems
like aljo led a breakout rendition of of
um and everybody sang along like serenad
Harry bellonte with his song the biggest
musicians biggest rock stars the biggest
acts in music at the time were all
singing and Stevie Wonder made up a
lyric about like him and Ry
driving like you know get in a car with
me and Ray behind the whe something like
that it was really like adorable but
[__] like that was like you know I what
we never saw that how beautiful how
human and how long they recorded into
the we hours of the morning it is called
what the greatest night the greatest
night in pop greatest night in pop it's
on Netflix right now um yeah I mean
there's there's also that bit I mean it
reminded me so much of what the vibe is
like in The Green Room of a comic book
invention yeah you know where like once
you remove kind of the trappings of
prestige and the elevation of station
and all that stuff everybody's a new for
something and so for like Diana Ross to
want to get like Cindy loper's autograph
and then suddenly they're all signing
each other's [__] sheet music
Suddenly It's this big Love Fest of like
you know Springsteen getting to talk to
you know Billy jeles again man we just
right across the bridge getting to talk
to B fonte getting to talk to whomever
like they were all just kids you know
playing with it's Theater Camp uh they
all just happen to be the biggest music
stars on the planet it's kind of wonder
um you know they Prince not being there
um and Prince was like I want to come in
and do a guitar solo they're like it's
not the spirit of the thing um so he
didn't come in and whatnot but they also
talked about [__] like the they wanted
David burn but he was on tour they
wanted Van Halen but they were on tour
um I had no idea it was recorded the
same night as the American Music Awards
that makes sense everyone was in town in
one place one time fascinating what what
do we got bman I was going to say I have
a Van Halen related story to the We Are
the World which is neither here nor
there
but uh Once Upon a Time the guy who
cleaned your turtle cage was looking for
a videographer and you gave him my
number he also cleaned the turtle cages
at Henson where that was recorded so I
went in with him for on a Sunday
afternoon for for hours and set up like
a 100 GoPros to tape him in a Hot for
Teacher drumming instructional video in
that room which that's tle that's Turtle
Mike he is a drummer yeah so we recorded
for hours Hot for Teacher in that room
but it was even at the end when I was
walking out of there you just felt how
like the the body that had been in that
place you feel the weight of that how
incredible that room is and how how
historic that is uh so I I got to hang
out and record Hot for Teacher in that
room uh nuts that's nuts I've never been
in that room I've been over to the
Henson Studios but I've never been on a
stage there and I'm sure if I was
somebody might have been like you know
what happened here but I've lived I've
lived up the block from there
since 2002 and had no idea that that's
other world was recorded it's crazy yeah
yeah they're like everybody got hungry
like one o'clock in the morning so we
got rosos chicken and waffles I like
[__]
rosos I loved when especially like I've
lived out here long enough you know I've
lived out here since 2002 and even
before that I [__] with Los Angeles
ever since you know [__] clerks got
picked up so seeing the old footage like
seeing the old rock and roll Ralphs on
on Sunset or Hollywood Hollywood Sunset
which one's it on maybe it's on
Hollywood I forget sunset sunset um was
[__] cool like holy [__] everything
else is gone the Ralph's is still
[__] there the sign is different so
[__] like that but all the all the
rest we
may did I drop that let's see no you're
on I'm on Kevin dropped for a second
he's back we're back and I'm Hardline
I'm hardwired in it may have been a zoom
issue you're back we're
good it's telling me my internet was
unstable but I'm hardwired
in what the [__] um
anyway cool what else we got uh we can
do some news my friend we can news it
up let's news it up man somebody said uh
Anthony Zapata said we I looked like
free Jack for a second
there Max Head
room uh so yes uh the there there's some
casting news this week um people coming
in to superhero movies and people coming
out of superhero movies okay person
coming in James gun um has found his
Supergirl for the upcoming
feature
um uh alas no no she don't no more she's
already done it I mean you know I
remember when listening to chistopher
eklon talking about whether he'd come
back as Doctor Who uh come back for
another doctor who you he's like you
don't you don't walk in the same river
twice he's like I did it I've done it to
come back to do it would be diminishing
returns he talked about doing you know a
a uh night country uh what's it called a
protective night country and he he said
like it's a small part and normally I
would have said no to it but the chance
to work with like my hero Jody Foster
was what made me do it I thought that
was Charming as hell because they both
look old in the show that's not a knock
I'm not going like they're all I mean of
course they if I'm 53 they're older than
me but that being said to see somebody
who's that old and who's been that a
accomplished in their field be like Oh
I'm a big jod Foster fan it's kind of
like [__] sweet like yeah makes you
go like oh my God he's even though he's
Doctor Who he's not that much different
than me he
also yeah I mean I I remember being at a
convention in the in the UK and the big
guest on the the top of the bill we were
both there to do a to do a fat man in
London and Cumberbatch was the big guest
and I remember being in the green room
where he was nervous as [__] hell to
meet John
C he was just like he was like a like
like a cat who like walked next to a fan
like he was just like I don't know what
what do I say like I've been do I walk
silly do I do the thing like I don't I
don't and just watching him like shake
his hands I'm the hugest fan in the
world thank you for everything like it's
just everybody's a fan of something and
so for eklon to be like yeah man like I
don't I wouldn't ordinarily want to go
to Iceland to shoot in a bunch of days
of night but is that where they're
shooting that that got it in Iceland in
Iceland
yeah I mean I'm not sure why yeah why
Alaska too far um I mean if I had to
guess it's just because Alaska might be
a little too developed in a certain way
like you just don't get those broad like
Tundras up there anymore or in a way
that's close enough to a production Hub
to be able to shoot but I think that
maybe rovic maybe something up there has
just the vibe they were looking
for um but yeah so at any rate um it is
not bissa Beno going back to be
Supergirl it is House of the Dragon
actress Millie Alcock who is she on that
show she played the young princess rera
Targaryen in the first season of House
of the Dragon um speak of which this is
gonna sound a little nam droppy but
George R Martin just texted me a few
hours ago oh what do he say I'm looking
for a word Kev goes can you help me
finish this book so everyone gets
off he was uh he said that right now his
he has his own movie theater as well the
Jean cocko movie theater Jean CTO
theater in uh New Mexico and I was he
came to SM Castle um last year and I was
supposed to go to his place and um you
know then I went into the nut house so
uh his he's right now he's like the
theater's closed because we're redoing
the bathrooms but when it opens can you
come and I was like [__] yeah I could
come come hard to your theater you know
he owns his own [__] trains like and
I don't mean like Choo Cho I mean ch ch
like a train that you could [__] ride
on
I mean everybody's got their something
that's that
[__] that's that Dragon money right
there yeah that throny money I remember
being on a zoom with him um a couple
years ago I think it was mid pandemic
when I was uh I was in early
conversations with HBO about potentially
doing one of the Game of Thrones
spin-offs and it's like we love you we
want to put you on the zoom with George
to make sure that he's signs off it's
like great and the entirety of the zoom
with George was like I was working at
starlog and writing articles about
Beauty and the Beast um when it was
coming out I was like oh yeah I love
starlog magazines again I wrote on
beauty the Beast I like I know that's
where I know your name from at first was
that and like you know wild cards and
and like the the awesome genre stuff
that you've done before Game of Thrones
you were familiar with wild cards yeah
he loves it he's so proud of wild cards
he's always talking about it he's like
you know I was doing comic books for
years before like were popular I know
yeah yeah we we were there we're old
enough um needless to say I didn't get
that job because uh he discovered
because I told him that I never read
that Game of Thrones
books so he's like nice meeting you
moving Yep this is a lovely Zoom but I
really think that a person who's going
to do one of these shows should have
read the books I said I was like listen
like I can tell you I think there might
be a virtue in not having read the books
um but hey man this is these are your
toys you get to decide who wants to play
with them and who doesn't
so thank you sir take care oh bman
popping in here the the Zinger back
could have just been I've been waiting
to get till you had them all written so
I could zoom through
them yeah that's a way to ensure you get
the job because you put it back on him
yeah um yeah he gets that everywhere man
I I posted I was like hey George R
Martins coming to SM castle and people
were like tell him to stay home and
finish his [__] book like I'm not
going to do that that I'm going welcome
him to my
theater seems
brusk but yes at any rate um Millie
Alcock is going to be playing um
Supergirl which is based basically on
the uh the Tom king um bilquis EV um
miniseries uh Supergirl women of
tomorrow um it is not clear who the
director is going to be it doesn't seem
as if um Mr Gunn is going to be
directing this he's very much focused on
Superman leg
but he's committed to to sort of
branching out and giving you the full
spectrum of the Kryptonian
experience um I'm I'm here for it just
hurry up tired of talking about this
[__] make it happen yeah it's you know I
know they only just started and we had a
big strike that we had to sit through
and they're about to start shooting the
movie but it's like enough talk let's
let's see some outfits Let's uh let me
wet my beak a little yeah like is nice
but let me see let me see somebody in an
outfit that's coming soon we'll see it
all patience kids yeah but that is the
the sort of perils of the open access to
the filmmaker which is like in the olden
days we'd get no access to anybody and
no information about anything until you
just saw a trailer like oh [__] I forgot
they were shooting that movie now we
just we know a lot and we're getting
updates that are not what you want or at
least not the thing not giving us a
thing you're telling me about the thing
um but yes um and similarly uh somebody
leaving a superhero movie um Emmy winner
IO ad Deb is leaving
Thunderbolts um oh she was gonna play
Julian luig rus' assistant yes um not
doing that no more not doing that no
more um she she don't need that she's a
[__] huge star for heaven's sakes she
don't need a bit part in a Marvel movie
I mean she she doesn't but then again
it'd be a bit part so wouldn't require a
ton of commitment and time on her part
theoretically but it's all scheduling
it's all production got pushed because
of the strikes and so the window that
she had had for Thunderbolts has closed
and she's being replaced by a woman
named Geraldine
viswanathan who was on um she's really
good actually on miracle workers that
was on TBS with Daniel redcliffe nice um
um but yeah and also Lewis Pullman Bill
Pullman's son who had been in Top Gun
Maverick um is replacing or it's unclear
if Steven young was ever cast um but uh
but that is now who's going to be
playing the Sentry is is Lewis
pman
I so
it's once again you know I I I mean I I
get it what we do is talk about things
long before they ever happen but it's
like come on just [__] show us a
movie already just go do the thing yeah
show Thunderbolts already we're tired of
waiting
stuff um yeah this this I think I'm
going to classify a little bit as a
rumor because the source is somewhat
unverified but according to the uh
website what's on
Netflix um the episode of Black Mirror
called USS
Callister um which had starred Jesse
plens and uh and and
Nicole motti know Christen motti um and
Michaela Cole is getting spun-off into a
three episode miniseries which will have
Jesse plem back Michaela pole back
Christin motti back um to sort of expand
on that particular episodes Universe
which and again if you don't remember
USS cister follows a story of of a
gaming company's uh Chief technology
officer is a mastermind behind a popular
multiplayer game and has a private copy
of it which he uses to torment his
colleagues who fail to show him proper
respect in the office um it's very Star
Trek it's very classic Trek um with
Jesse plens as both the captain and the
Tormentor um and it's great it's one of
the best blue Black Mirror episodes ever
so to get a larger version of that story
to get more [__] weird ass trekk and
space stuff from Charlie Brooker yes
please yeah I'll I'll watch anything
Charlie Brooker [__] does somebody in
chat said one of us has a really boring
voice Marty Landon goes this guy's voice
is so boring sorry me or you who it is
it's probably me because he said it
while I I don't know I think he might
have said I think he's talking about me
which I really [__] resent the notion
that I'm referred to as this
guy this guy you're on literally
youtube.com Kevin Smith like you didn't
get here by
accident not like you stumbl into a bar
on Hollywood Boulevard and was like
what's happening in
here um all right yeah finally last bit
of news um which I found kind of
encouraging DIY film said boring enough
for AM radio [__]
it traffic we're gonna be [__] AM
radio rich
kids we're gonna be drowning in nickels
you just you wait you know that money
that the [__] smartless podcast just
got paid by SiriusXM peanuts compared AM
radio money that's in our future yeah AM
radio is the Superman 3 grift where we
just take
half all those half cents will be
[Laughter]
ours um screenwriter David ke who uh who
wrote the original Jurassic Park in its
sequel Jurassic Park Lost World um he
wrote um
Indiana Jones and the Crystal Skull uh
he wrote the first Spider-Man movie the
original Mission Impossible movie one of
Hollywood's legendary screenwriters has
been working on a new Jurassic world
movie um with Spielberg to produce and
um as well as Frank Marshall um it's
unclear what The Narrative of this movie
is of course I going to keep this super
super secret but it is known to be
launching a new Jurassic era um per
sources which would seem to rule out the
return of Chris Pratt or Bryce Dallas
Howard as well as Sam Neil Laura dur
Andor Jeff goldoon um they are they are
soft rebooting it because why wouldn't
you everybody [__] likes
dinosaurs and it's a it's [__]
concept nobody gets tired of like
[__] they shouldn't have done that
Park but they did it now they're gonna
[__] pay won't they ever
learn I mean look I don't fault them of
course like you know it's a [__] cash
cow for them and stuff and by starting
again without any of the other people
you don't have to pay them legacy cast
[__] prices and [__] like that um and
at the end of the day you know I'm not
taking anything away from the [__]
actors and like they bring absolutely
something to it but come on they're
going for the
dinosaurs yes we are not here for the
humans it's the anti-g goodzilla minus
one Godzilla minus one did get an Oscar
nomination it did sadly not for best
foreign language film but really should
I can't believe they didn't run that I
can't believe that wasn't the submission
for Japan like
[__] I I I would have bet the house
on that like [__] what other foreign
film was gonna beat that in that
category I mean I'm glad they got
nominated for anything but like I feel
that was that was an amazing film
Amazing yeah so strong I mean and you
know I I saw the the it was on X or or
blue sky or wherever it was the video of
the VFX team learning that they got
nominated for an Oscar and it was like
the most adorable thing ever because
they're just so [__] excited you know
like never thought we'd be here we made
a Godzilla movie for cheap for cheap
they didn't have the [__] money man
you look at that movie you don't realize
how much money they did it for it's it's
astounding when I afterwards I was like
how much was it and I [__] looked how
they made it and [__] all love man all
love somebody was like I know how to do
this make it work and once again I've
always been that guy that's like [__]
the human story more monsters beating
each other up make the movie 45 minutes
and just let the monsters fight this is
the first time that I was like you know
what can Godzilla get out of the way
because the human story is really
compelling so Jurassic Park man I mean I
know it's apples and oranges but like
you got a high bar because Godzilla they
should do like Godzilla minus one
version
Jurassic Park minus one
exactly I wonder if they'll go back and
tell Like An Origin story like [__]
um you know John whatever [__] young
John Hammond yeah something like that
but no because then it's
like him hunting for
Amber yeah and I guess he could get into
some scraps or whatever some jams but
like what Jam is bigger than like I open
the park and it [__] everything
eating everything else it ate
everybody um but good for them Universal
the headline here kids that headline
again Universal still knows how to print
money they do $6 billion dollar so far
for the Jurassic franchise and only more
coming this is why they won't make
Twilight of the Mall Rats they're like
have you made us any billions the
dinosaurs made us six of them
six dinosaurs never grow old and they
never die
truly um all right well there it is more
[__] coming our way children love a
dinosaur fancy that um and that's it for
the news my friend uh let's throw in
[__] like Deanne wo is coming back for
Daredevil as is uh foggy as is uh
um yes as you said foggy what is name um
Elden something something El elen
something he he was wonderful as fogy
and it felt so bad when you heard
they're making Daredevil but those cats
a coming back it's like how you going to
do without foggy Karen Paige and you
know they're they as we've heard they
pulled everything back and we're redoing
it and now they're doing the right thing
and bringing in everybody they made they
made the Netflix show Canon yeah so I'm
here for man uh there was other news oh
did you see the new Ghostbusters trailer
I did see the new Ghostbusters trailer
doesn't it look like they're doing
Ghostbusters the cartoon as a liveaction
movie yeah like I am [__] there for
it man that's how they cracked the code
this time where they're like look you
know [__] last time we brought back
the ghost of [__] Harold Ramos for
heaven's sakes how do we top that I
think it was fantastic to be like let's
just do an episode of the show kind
of um I can't wait that looks fun as
[__] and all of our Ghostbuster heroes
from our childhood are back and they are
they are I mean it
does there is a there is the weirdness
of like either you commit to having new
Ghostbusters or you just give us another
old
busters but the weird like suddenly we
have to give some breathing space for
Paul Rudd to kind of just be Paul Rudd
I'm like a I like my my my level of
interest in the Paul rut of it all is
not that high whereas I dug the kids and
I'm here for Bill Murray and Dan arroy
and Ernie Hudson um but it's the the the
the mid space that's kind of
odd um in chat in chat they're saying
talk about the curse did you watch the
curse I have not watched The Curse have
you loved it loved Nine episodes of it I
was like Jesus Christ man like [__]
this is groundbreaking television and
then the 10th episode I respect what
they did but like they made a choice
they they made a choice that you know
some people are like no it's in keeping
with the previous nine but I'm like
really I didn't see that coming at all
um
but it's to totally worth your time and
watch I think Nathan fielders kind of
brilliant Emma Stone's excellent in it
Benny saf's ex excellent in it um yeah I
think excuse me I think he's
also because Nathan directed a bunch of
episodes I think he's a very strong
director I was watching his shows and
I'm like I think this guy's a better
director than I am like
compositionally um you know the Nuance
of Storytelling through a visual medium
uh I I was very impressed but yeah it's
a great show if you haven't seen it yeah
may leave you being like you know
fighting with
people in chat they're going like uh
it's a twin peakish Choice twin peakish
Choice absolutely I would not argue that
I would absolutely coign that
outstanding um somebody in chat
mentioned uh the monkey man trailer did
you see that trailer I haven't seen it
yet how is it
it's pretty great it's pretty great Dev
Patel um wrote Stars and directed it um
because I'm sure he was like nobody's
offering me these roles nobody's
offering me the [__] Action Hero
nobody's offering me Dev Wick and I
really want a [__] Dev Wick and
that's the movie um and it looks like
both stylized and action heavy and funny
and satirical and you know very
specifically kind of a a a movie for the
the Indian diaspora in a way that like
your average Bollywood movie is not um
and apparently Netflix who had sort of I
guess commissioned it and produced it
didn't want it because I think there
were some cuts that that they wanted him
to make to play nflix India that he was
unwilling to make they gave him the
movie back Jordan Peele saw it was like
[__] yeah let's do it like and so monkey
paw picked it up and Universal is
releasing it in April and it it looks
great it looks great and he looks great
like why wouldn't you have given this
dude an action movie he's Oscar
nominated he [__] Dev Patel like let
him do the thing was it was he in Green
Knight he was in Green Knight um he was
in Lion he was of course in slub Dog
Millionaire like he's been he's been
working for a good decade decade and a
half at just like good [__] for a while
and so here for that um even though our
our poster for this week was Avatar The
Last Airbender um we haven't talked
about that trailer which I'm I am I was
already a given for that show because I
love you love the series The Animated
Series I love the Animated Series I love
it you know and all right wait
head-to-head matchup Avatar or blue-eyed
Samurai um
Avatar only because it got three full
seasons it got to do it it got to tell
its story whereas bluee Samurai which I
think is again phenomenal we've only
seen a season of it so you know there's
there's a chance it falls off the The
Wagon I'm not sure but I think that like
looking at it it's giving me big um One
Piece Vibes um which is like based on a
long running anime um but it's taking
the best lessons from the anime but also
realizing that like this is live action
this is real this
is concessions will need to be made
adaptations will need to be made but
they [__] cast it so well it looks
great
um yeah man I of the things I cannot
wait for it is high on the
list um they're asking if we've seen the
trailer for three body problem from The
Game of Thrones creators have you seen
the trailer I did not I did um I've have
no idea what it's about but then again
um I think that might be by Design
because I think the book that it's based
on is very complex and twisty and and
full of some real headyy sci-fi concept
which don't lend well to like two
minutes of whizbang um but I'm for sure
curious
because you know for six
seasons you know uh those guys made
great television great great television
and so yeah and the last season was just
okay so I'm very curious about what they
do
next um in chat they are also asking us
about
um oh I just missed
it um there was something that we might
as
well way in on now I can't find it oh
Awards talk they want to talk about the
Oscars and the snubs I mean well let's
talk about the most obvious SN which I
did on the radio last week when I was on
KFI
AM AM radio kids the future
of am
um we were uh I talked about somebody
was like hey uh you know what about
Greta Gerwig getting
SN um I like I'm old enough to remember
when Driving Miss Daisy was nominated
for an Oscar uh but Bruce barisford the
director wasn't and I remember as a
young kid being like how how does that
happened you know one of the jokes on
the Oscars that year was like Driving
Miss Daisy the movie that drove itself
because the director ctor did not get
nominated I don't think I've ever seen
many
movies that are as a much a part a
product of the
filmmaker as the Director particularly
as Barbie was like the fact that it was
nominated for best picture and she's not
nominated for best actor is aside from
the Optics of that just [__] crazy
but it's not like it hasn't happened
before and when
it's always like crazy but this is
really crazy because it's like she was
nominated for [__] ladybird like it's
not like this is her first dance they
already love her how did she not get
nominated is beyond me and this is this
is not like you know this is a director
speaking I I just I can't understand how
you could nominate that movie you could
nominate the
screenplay but you're like you know I
mean anybody could have done that it's
like no that was a sing singular work of
of a very particular artist it to me
it's baffling but you know at the same
time you're talking to a guy who really
doesn't give a [__] about
Awards you know but if I'm I'm sure like
it would have been like insanely
rewarding
for Greta Gerwig to be acknowledged by
you know the academy for [__] like
doing something
that was insanely original she made a
[__] toy commercial that like I could
watch again and again and again
and that toy commercial had heart and
[__] soul and breathed and made you
feel and [__] laugh and like it was
crazy so I know Margo wasn't Margo
Robbie Roby Robbie I never remember um
was wasn't nominated as well and
honestly that I I'm not saying like well
of course she wasn't but that didn't
surprise me as much as Greta not getting
nominated um for some reason even though
Margot is Barbie but
like even you know I'm sure the movie
don't exist without Margo either but it
it it was of a voice of a very
particularly strong voice of an artist
and not just in the screenplay
department but also visually how it lays
out like the entire [__] world like I
I don't it just felt weird that she
didn't get a nod but again you're
talking to a guy who's like [__] like
awards that means it's you know it's it
doesn't take anything away from the fact
that she has a
Titanic achievement in cinema not just
modern Cinema but across the Hundred
Years of the [__] form that movie is
is a massive accomplishment and and just
wonderful makes you feel good and [__]
and this is a byproduct of the academy
and this and please don't I know some
people are going to be like he went on a
rant this is not me I'm not telling
anybody to change a [__] thing I I
have no power here and I'm not saying
like let's write in or some [__] like
that it's just weird to me that like
somebody who's that
distinctive making a movie that
distinctive doesn't get like shouted out
for but when you nominate 10 films for
best picture and only nominate five
people for best
director this is bound to happen I'm
just shocked it happened in this case
yeah I mean as you say it's not this is
not the first time it's happened yeah
it's happened both well not many but
it's happened right for for both the
director of a film not being nominated
though the picture itself is nominated
for Best Picture Ben was not nominated
for I don't think Ben was nominated for
Argo he wasn't and Argo still won you
know and he was also the producer of it
so he got to give his speech um Barbara
stran was not nominated for Prince of
Tides um as director right yeah although
the movie was nominated for Best Picture
yeah the movie was but she didn't get
nominated she didn't get nominated um so
like it's not an isolated occurrence um
it it doesn't quite feel like this weird
anti-feminist thing that I think some
people have made it out to be because
like yeah but there's another female
director nominated in directors Margo is
nominated for best producer for best
picture as is Greta Greta got best
screenplay America Ferrara got a best
supporting actress nomination like it is
not if the movie went unrecognized the
Oscars it is just that one that felt
like it would be the obvious one Luke
Sky wanker great name in chat out the
DGA did nominate Greta Gerwig so the DGA
was like we recognize what happen here
for this yeah um at least the DG yeah
whatever members of the DGA are also in
the academy because the directors
nominate their peers um it would seem
that those two things are not in lock
step but I honestly felt like that they
would have been U kinder to air I
thought air was wonderful and I thought
Affleck did a phenomenal job um I could
I was kind of a little disappointed that
there was no not love for air I thought
like even though that came out in
[__] February or March I thought like
the academy would remember but they
almost never do yeah you know name the
movie that came out in February that the
academy remembered the following
year no I don't know has to do with
somebody we spoke very highly of this
evening
uh oh yeah no I guess I guess it was um
silence the Lambs was a came out
February and they still Remembered in
[__] March or April of the next year
they they [__] won like that that's
always the one they point to just like
when somebody back in the day was like
we're putting on your you're putting
your show on Mid season and you're like
midseason nobody watched TV they're like
that's where Seinfeld started in
midseason right I mean the
the listen Sansa lens is an amazing
[__] movie that was 1994 if I believe
which was a completely different media
landscape and also that movie played in
theaters for like five months so it got
to ride through the summer and got to
end its run in like August I think and
yeah but nevertheless um Anthony in chat
says why the disparity between the
number of best picture and director
nominations that happened fairly
recently I believe it was round the dark
night is when Academy was like look we
nominate five movies and they're
generally all Prestige movies and
mainstream doesn't get a bite we're
losing ratings so let's increase the
best picture nods to 10 and leave
everything else at five right
which honestly doesn't really make a
[__] ton of sense it it's literally like
you know we just want to give you a
thing viewer that you have seen in the
movies basically it's like the
Blockbuster addendum like we can
nominate popular movies that The
viewership will not have had to see this
tiny Woody Allen movie or this tiny
Iranian movie or this whatever it is
it's like no it's [__] Lord of the
Rings it's you know dark night it's you
know every every like six years there
would be the Titanic or you know Avatar
or whatever the big ass movie that was
also nominated for bunch of [__] but for
the most part it's almost never that way
it was like a couple years after the
artist won best picture like what is
this movie what is this little black and
white French movie that's subtitled this
is something look I don't make [__]
Academy worthy [__] never wanted to I'm
I'm not I never went into this business
for awards or anything like that in the
beginning of my career they're very nice
clerks won awards at K it won two Awards
of K the bried elij Jess and the
international critics week prize we won
a filmmaker trophy at Sundance and stuff
um and I was once told by my publicist
at the time that he was told by Writers
Guild folks that Chasing Amy Academy
folks because he worked with the academy
uh Chasing Amy came within two [__]
votes of being in the five nominees for
screenplay that year and I was like oh
that's [__] badass to hear but again
was never the aim and stuff so when I
say this this doesn't come from any sort
of bias and I'm not saying this this is
why I've never won an Oscar I've never
an Oscar and I'll never win an Oscar
because I'm not good I'm not good like
enough to win an Oscar so let's just get
that out of the way so I can say this
winning an Oscar is not always based on
Merit because there are wonderful films
groundbreaking films that don't get
nominated um it is it has a it's there's
a lot of campaigning and a lot of money
to get spent um to run a film for for
best picture like naive eely years ago I
was like hey man Michael Parks gives an
Academy award-worthy performance in Red
State like can't we run him for an Oscar
can't we like how do you get a guy
nominated and my publicist at the time
was just like I work with the academy
Kevin unless you're willing to spend
half a million dollars you're not even
going to come close to the conversation
I was like what are you talking about
he's like it's a campaign it's like
running for [__] office and stuff
like that and it's not poola it's not
like oh you got to pay off people it's
just it's ads the only thing that keeps
like [__] The Hollywood Reporter and
variety going to this day are those
[__] for your consideration ads
that's a huge business for them so I'm
not and again I'm not saying all this to
be like that's why I'll never win one
more time I'll say it up front so I'm
not misquoted online I will never win
anything because I'm not good enough to
win a thing but that being said even if
you're good enough to win a thing it
costs a lot of money to even get into
the [__] race you have heard the same
things I mean I mean it's it's it's a
yes A student has to be willing to spend
the money but B it has to be like the
Academy Award nominations and wins are
reflective of what the academy wants to
say about itself any given year the
narrative it wants to put forth a great
narrative will do more for a thing than
the equality will do it's
like Robert dowy Jr is probably going to
win an Oscar this year was his
performance in in Oppenheimer the best
performance I don't know it's really
good is it better than Sterling K Brown
I don't know is it better than anybody
else I'm not sure but I haven't seen the
Sterling I haven't seen America American
fiction yeah I haven't seen it yet but I
will say this Robert Downey Jr's
performance like that that's what I
walked away from Oppenheimer with the
most like I was like Jesus Robert Downey
Jr disappeared and literally became
somebody else and that's hard for a guy
who's that identifiable and has been
essentially playing a version of himself
for the last 10 years in Marvel films
and stuff like that for him to disappear
and become somebody else and make me
forget that that was Robert D Jr that
was [__] impressive I mean and and
again not taking anything away from that
yeah but the Robert Downey Jr of today
running for an Oscar lets the narrative
be here's a guy we've always rooted for
here's a guy we've always loved here's a
guy we nominated once too early for
chaplain now's his time it's the the
we're giving Denzel and Oscar for
training day instead of for Malcolm X
like we realized we should have done it
we [__] it up now we'll fix it for him
just playing the kind of character we
always kind of wanted him to play which
was bad cop nasty dude whatever Jam Lee
Curtis winning Oscar she's great in
everything everywhere all at once is she
better than Stephanie XU who played the
sort of pivotal character of the movie I
don't think so but Jamie Curtis her
narrative to getting up to Oscar gold is
amazing like horror queen nepple baby
who's always made good I've been doing
good work for a long time finally is
getting her due like it's the narrative
around it why does greenbook win because
Hollywood wants to pretend it
understands race this is our movie about
race in America and we fixed it
everybody we just have to be nice to
each other as opposed to other movies
about race that never get nominated you
know like it's it's all always what the
narrative around the particular nominee
is and what Hollywood decides and wants
to say about itself this year you know
and are you willing to [__] press the
flesh like American fiction is a tiny
movie that cost like $12 million that
sort of Amazon and MGM bought out of
Toronto but it's been four months since
that movie premiered at Toronto and
they've been working it working it hard
they've been going to all these
festivals they've been doing every event
you know Corey Jefferson um who's a
super sweet guy has been someplace every
third day to do some kind of Q&A
screening to do some kind of piece of
press to do some kind of whatever same
thing with Jeffrey Wright same thing
with stering K Brown like they've just
been out working it like running for
office and it's hard but the narrative
around that movie is Emmy winning
television writer um voice of a
generation young African-American dude
like
speaks well very articulate like all of
the the sort of buzzworthy whistle dog
whistly kind of things about a young
black dude who made a movie like he's
the next Spike Lee he's whatever the
narrative is strong
like that's that's what it's about it's
about can you spend the money and do you
have the story it is rarely about what's
the best movie Calvin lemon in chat like
made me [__] type while I'm doing the
show because I was like like is that
true he said look at Napoleon Dynamite
gets Oscar nomination came close to the
Academy Awards and that was a another
smaller film and I was like did Napoleon
Dynamite get nominated for an Academy
Award did I memory hole that and I
googled that and that's not true at
all so I does anybody why why did he say
that is maybe he just thought it did but
it said here got close it said at 13 MTV
Movie
Awards um which is not insignificant it
was nominated for an independent Spirit
award which makes sense but let me see
Critics Choice Award satellite Awards
Grammy awards for soundtrack The
Independent Spirit Awards the MTV Movie
Awards the online critic Society
Sundance Film Festival Teen Choice
Awards us comedy Arts Festival golden
trailer Awards golden schmo's yeah
there's no Academy in
year yeah close I mean hey I got the
release saying it's not like a Beloved
movie but like I was like I've I don't
remember that at all yeah I I I got the
release date for SS of the Lambs wrong
so not everybody's perfect it's 91 not
94 John Thompson says MTV Movie Awards
is perfect for Barbie not the Oscars
you're all off your rockers I mean look
whether you like Barbie or not like you
have to admit it was a [__] cultural
phenomenon like you know
shoulder-to-shoulder with Oppenheimer so
much so that [__] the whole summer
was called barbin Heimer for heaven s um
you don't have to like the movie but
like it's it's not like yeah that could
be on the MTV Movie Awards like no it it
definitely deserves to get nominated
point is the director should have been
nominated as well but our point was
there have been times in the past where
that has not been the case right and so
like half I forgot about that yeah I
mean and yeah like what will happen now
is that Barbie will lose best picture um
to Oppenheimer um it will win best
adapted screenplay even though it's not
adapted from anything beyond a doll that
exists and that's also a very tight
category as well yeah they would have
been better off in the best original
screenplay category but they didn't pick
it I think the academy just shov into
there yeah they decided that it was
adapted you know which I think American
fiction would have won best adapted
screenplay if Barbie hadn't thrown in
there because that is again the kind of
that screenplay is always the they throw
to filmmakers especially on the come up
um to to say you know we loved your
movie we didn't we can't give it the big
prizes but here's like the lower rung of
the adult Awards it's not a craft award
it's not a tech award it's like no this
is a creative thing you guys wrote
something that's
great so I feel a little
bad um all right so I think that's I
think we covered everything that they
wanted us to talk about in chat yeah um
and so we finished the news finished the
news finished the views talked about our
views um should we do some cues we can
yeah remind folks hey B man throw up
that odds of Mark Fatman
Beyond Live graphic kids March 15th in
the great state of New Jersey the Garden
State at SM Castle
Cinemas um were they're playing Stripes
this week oh very nice Stripes yes uh
the odds of Mark return March 15th me
and Mark are doing fat man Beyond at SM
Castle Cinemas right there in Atlantic
Islands New Jersey uh right after the
show stick around for free screening
secret screening not GNA tell you what
it is
but but doves May Cry how could you just
leave us
standing come
on um and then next day there's more
odds of Mark fun with screenings of
Blade and screenings of Doomsday but uh
come see us do Fatman you get tickets
right now at smast cinemas.com go we'll
wait we're not saying another [__]
word until 100 tickets
sell I'm bored let's
talk um so yeah do we have any do we
have any cues oh man uh we do before we
go into it yeah I want to give a shout
out to I think it was Mike who loves the
show and his wife who uh bumped into me
at Nordstrom Rack in Burbank uh they
were super nice they pretended as if I
didn't smell bad because I hadn't
showered in a couple days um so shout
out to them because they said they've
watched the show for years and they love
it so I think it was Mike might have
nice Mike somebody else celebrity
celebrity sighting [__] B man um also
just cuz I'm going to promote my own
stuff for a second uh if you guys want
to give us a follow on Instagram and on
Tick Tock we're doing some really cool
stuff I went
through uh and I went and picked out
this like every geeky
event that's like ever happened so like
yesterday did you guys know yesterday
was Arthur Curry's in Universe birthday
so we had really man's birthday it was
Aquaman's birthday so we're going to be
posting about stuff like that I have
dates like uh dick Grayson's in Universe
birthday the date that Martha uh the the
Wayne parents were killed Thomas and
Martha Wayne so uh we're going to be
celebrating all sorts of stuff like that
uh Superman's birthday do you guys know
when Superman's in Universe birthday is
coming soon February February
29th Superman was born or was discovered
on leap day so we're going to do fun
stuff like that um and we have a brand
new cocktail menu uh with some fun stuff
did you say cocktail CU c
k I just want to watch you drink
it so uh we've been doing uh some fun
videos I'll show you guys this you might
think it's
cool this is uh our new Lord of the
Rings drink and if you hit it with a
black light it uh
it glows in the dark it has do the
script so um lot of fun stuff uh there
so anyway uh now I've got Q&A for
everybody because they have Dixon Cider
pointed out in chat that Aquaman 2
Cracked 400 million at the box
office um which you know is a very
that's it's a big number um it's
respectable the it is but the first
Aquaman was a billion dollars so
um but you know of the of the year that
DC has had has anyone else cracked 400
million like did Flash Blue Beetle
Shazam nope so that's a big
accomplishment for for
Aquaman whose birthday just passed as we
heard happy birthday Aquaman Superman's
next actually I think one I think
Batman's birthday is mid-February I
think it's cool and you the birthdays at
the bar yeah we're going to have
birthday parties for everybody every
every big character at the bar this year
that's so clever kids if you've never
been to the scum and villain Cantina
like make it a make it a point to get
there once in your life man that it's
fun [__] like that that's a good idea
that's a really good idea we did um
karaoke we had karaoke last night and we
did um I see if I still have it uh oh
it's not on there we did uh I said come
sing in an ocean related song for
Aquaman's birthday we'll get you a drink
so I suggested like Ocean Avenue from
yellow card and how far will go how far
I'll go from Moana a lot of good ocean
songs out there no good Aquaman songs
could you have done a Billy Ocean
covered Billy Ocean and
not Queen
yes uh so just fun stuff like that we're
gonna we're going to have some fun with
it Superman's birthday is also on a
karaoke night uh Thursday February 29th
uh so we're going to have birthday cake
and special drinks and um a lot of
really good Superman related karaoke
songs get your asses to the scum and
villainy cantina kids located in
Hollywood California right on Hollywood
Boulevard man we're all the
stars hang out right on Hollywood
Boulevard you're walking down Holly
Boulevard you're seeing hey there's
George cloney there's Feldman there's
[__] Lindsay Wagner it's crazy yes I
was sitting at the bar last Wednesday
after trivia speaking of and and kid
from kid in play was there how what is
that sitting at the bar next to me I
didn't recognize him cuz his hair was
normal or un normal for us unnormal for
him but uh you got royalty in that bar
right there how cool is that yeah just
hanging out at the bar
nice do a little y'all like this y'all
like that y'
feel I feel it I feel it y'all make a
little love
y' this part's at the fun house this
part's at
the we had um young Han Solo walk in uh
Alden Aaron Reich walked in one one day
I wasn't there and uh and the employee
said uh he's like they're like Alden
Aron Reich walked in looked around and
just goes nope and walked right back out
like he didn't know what he walking into
can you imagine Han Solo walking into
the Cana and he's just like nope not
tonight not doing
this oh man let's do but we scanned his
ID at the door so I know where he
lives you can find Han Solo you should
maybe not say that [__] out loud
man I keep a database of all the famous
people come to the bars so I can knock
on their doors and leave [__] in the bag
in their Stoops I I thought um you know
they it was I don't think the audience
is ready to watch other people be
characters they've known and loved for
years so I think that was kind of one of
the problems with that Han Solo movie
that being or solo that being said I
thought he was great I thought he was
great too he was not the problems I had
with that movie at all I agreed 100 per.
he was he was really good and I've seen
him in other things he was good in that
too good in
Oppenheimer you know who's [__] good
in Oppenheimer and didn't get a nod but
like really is like [__] the glue and
he's playing the [__] Paul Newman
part from fat man and little boy was
Maddie Matt Damon was so [__] good in
Oppenheimer
I wouldn't given him a nod just because
I'm like wow that [__] Charming but
uh but I'm I'm biased but I I liked him
a lot in that
movie yeah I mean looking our boy Dave
desalin was good everybody's good Dave
Des smalin's movie is coming soon man
late
night can't wait March March or April um
all right
Jas all right uh Max fle wanted to know
uh what obscure 80s or 7s cartoon tune
would you want to
remake I I did it I guess it wasn't so
not really obscure yeah good point all
right obscure 70s 80s
cartoon um I I it's not like I would
want to remake it but I think it's ripe
for touching and that sounds far [__]
more disturbing and filthier than I
meant hey are you R yeah you ripe for
touching uh Star Blazers we're all off
to outer
space leaving Mother Earth to save the
human race our Star Blazers they had a
bad guy that kind of was like Darth
Vader esque had a cool mask team you
know [__] like in space that you
could totally do that today um but let
me
see I can do
anything even like wait till your father
gets wait till your father gets wait
father gets home one of the only Hannah
barara cartoons to debut in prime time
like
Flintstones
um I might I might go with Star Blazers
I think that could totally transfer over
and I watched a [__] ton of
that um or I was a big fan of the
Dungeons and Dragons cartoon oh yeah Lov
that cartoon man I thought it was so
cool uh [__] could cool stories where
like you know I guess it's not that
different than what they did with the
Jumanji movies lately right people get
kind of sucked into a world and stuff
but yeah I like they they had a cool bad
guy um yeah Dungeons and Dragons would
be a fun fun one to do as well what
about you
Mark um I mean chat seems to want
Thundercats um somebody should do
Thundercats but it should be somebody
that knows the lure very well and that's
not me what about you also not
obscure cat was huge yeah if you said
Silver Hawks which was like thundercast
but what if they were Birds um is way
more obscure but not that one um I was a
big fan of Galaxy
Rangers um which was like you know a
little bit X-Men a little bit Firefly
before Firefly you know but it was a
Western in space they rode [__] robot
horses and [__] and they were just check
it was all about the frontier and these
these four you know enhanced individuals
who got to patrol the frontier and solve
crimes every week and deal with rustlers
and all that [__] like but it was just
it was cool there was a vibe to it that
I always dug
um yeah I think it'd be it'd be Galaxy
Rangers for me B man look up Space
Battleship Yamato 3199 cuz argon nut
says Space Battleship Yamato 3199 starts
in July why too late Kevin is that was
that name different from Star Blazers I
thought those was two different
things uh I'm seeing
Space Battleship Yamato remake anime
is be forever Yamato Rebel
sequel but that's not star blad I don't
think that's Star
Blazers
um
maybe it's what's makes it's an
interesting question what makes it
difficult is the fact that it has to be
obscure right because like naturally we
could think of like oh this this but
it's like no it's got to be something
that not everyone [__] knew that well
I uh you know silvercloud has one gem oh
well they just made a movie three years
ago Jim in the may I may I tell you a
story tell me a story it's now okay to
tell on you know it kind of I believe um
I wrote a gem script you wrote a draft
me and the kid together we're hired to
write um a pilot of a gem series live
live
action um it was when Netflix was like
we're spending crazy money and uh it was
I you know I shockingly knew a lot about
jet another cartoon that like Masters I
would watch because it was made it was a
Marvel cartoon at the time like it was
made by Marvel Productions they had a
credit at the end of it and it was a
very like you know super heroy oriented
like dual identities she runs the record
label but Jerica is also secretly gem
the biggest [__] act in the world and
they had their own super villains with
the Misfits and [__] like that and
Pizzazz so um I I did write a gem uh
script and um the pilot of a 10 episode
series in Stu it's not happening um but
I had a blast doing it I and the other
day I was like oh maybe it could be
animated but it would have been an
expensive live action show but I was
encouraged to I was told to write it
live action um but uh you probably still
get away with an animated yeah I would
[__] I mean probably gem didn't leap
to mine because I was like I did that
right it didn't pan out but that gem
would be great for [__] and you know
I don't know if one would consider that
as popular as [__] Thundercats or
something something maybe that is a
little more obscure is well known but
definitely not as well known as Masters
or or um Thundercats or you know
[__] the Animated Series there's my
show I'd like to redo Batman the
anime I mean I I don't know I don't
remember if it's 60s or 70s it feels
like it's late 60s early 7s and not
obscure but Johnny Quest feels like it's
kind of
overdue um a kind of reboot rehab re re
uh refreshening
Rejuvenation easy enough to do too like
in ter like you've got your full
mythology right there I mean it could be
argued that um who is doing it on Adult
Swim that that cartoon the adventure
Brothers they you know they're like hey
we've been doing it for years yeah
except like it stopped being Johnny
Quest and became its own weird ass thing
after like season two or three which
power to them they just I think got
bored doing Johnny Quest and was like
all right what if there's
what if there's more things what if
there's henchmen what if there's all
this stuff some good suggestions from uh
from uh the chat
ready um yes Argo nut says number one
starblazers is the English dub of Space
Battleship Yamato so they are making
which is I'm all for it I don't need to
make it myself I'm just glad is doing it
um Ryan Landis suggested groovy Ghoulies
in a heartbeat oh my God I would love to
do that that um and ridge flyer 32 said
Space
Ghost absolutely I I I don't know if one
would consider that
obscure but uh Space Ghost would be
[__] astounding you could do a
[__] awesome version of modern day
Space Ghost yeah yeah I mean I want to
do thundar also I don't know how obscure
thundar is but F the Barbarian Lords of
light with UA the mock which was named
after the
UCLA are you serious
yeah that's where the name comes
from wow yeah
idea I always I always pronounced
itaa
W um all right JC give us another one oh
I love just real quick I don't know
because nobody said it there was like
this really obscure cartoon called gar
and the golden
Lance uh that was kind of like a he-man
meets Conan the Barbarian is
um cartoon and then uh I think though if
I could do anything it would be the
filmation
Ghostbusters bring back that one with
the monkey and the car somebody
suggested that they're like Ghostbusters
but with the with the ape
like which itself based on a live action
show the uh question number
two um I've had some time to think about
this so I can lead uh Jacob Adcock
wanted to know uh if the three of us
could collaborate on something besides
movies and I'm assuming a podcast uh
what would you do uh he says you are
also creative explore your passions and
let us
know stage stage
play I think we raise a big baby oh my
God three nerds and a baby what a kid
we'd ra oh my God so well-versed things
that aren't real and don't
matter oh um you
know I bet you we could run a good
business yeah I was going to say like a
restaurant but I feel like that's too
easy easy like it's kind already there
what if there was a club that was a bar
but we could also do a show
at don't knock it till we try it imagine
imagine
k um what a weird interesting question I
thought it would be fun clearly a comic
book clearly a movie
script a movie like me and Mark could
write it and JC could [__] direct it
um and JC is also [__] something of
writer himself did you like yoga hoser
kids guess who invited guess who
invented the bris that was [__] JC
that guy J once told me a story him and
Andrew our beloved Andrew from [__]
uh you know when we do the show live um
they were talking about a lowbudget
movie they wanted to do where these kids
come across all these little Hitler
clones miniature Hitler clones and it's
kind of like Gremlins and I was like
that's [__]
dope I was said can I have that and
they're like I guess and
Yogo was born I mean I feel like that
version of Yogo there was another
version of Yogo that didn't have cool
little
bris but that that it started with JC
and Andrew and [__] so yeah and he can
he could write as well all three of us
could write I'd let him direct though
although all three of us have directed
as well speaking of directing yes sir
when can they watch Splinter we talked
about it a minute ago but we didn't
[__] put up the graphic throw up the
graphic
JC uh I don't think I gave him a
splinter graphic I don't have a splinter
graphic well that maybe that's why we
didn't put one up kid tell them what's
happening on Friday with Splinter yeah I
mean I have been thinking about it for a
while you know what to do with the short
now that the sort of Festival run is
mostly over there's a couple more
festivals we have we're we're we're
playing I think I don't know if I can
announce where yet I think it's a little
bit too early but there's a at the very
least two festivals one on the west
coast one in the in the middle of the
country coming up in the next few months
there's a couple more festivals we're
out at but for the most part we're kind
of done with that circuit so it's like
what are we going to do with it like
what's where's it going to live what's
it going to how's it going to exist from
now on and the idea was always like just
[__] make it free on the internet
like I don't want to charge people for
it I don't want to make people buy it to
stream it you know the fan base has been
so [__] generous to jump from the
beginning of like giving me money to
help make it I don't need to get more
money from people so rather than
continue to deliberate on this thing I
just said you know what we'll just turn
the link live we'll just turn it public
and so come this Friday um I will I will
gladly promote it I will gladly share
where that link is but just [__] it you
get to watch it now if you were not a
Kickstarter backer if you were if you
live in the UK or the UAE or Australia
wherever it is and you have the internet
I don't think we're going to region lock
it so just like yeah just enjoy it's
there for everybody now look at that man
after hearing about it here after
hearing about it for a long time you're
going to see directorial debut on Friday
we're doing it tell you where to find it
what is what on your socials and [__] I
I'll broadcast on the socials minus
Twitter because I don't do that anymore
um although I might just come back just
to do that might as well put it up let
that be your last tweet like hey yeah
watch the movie here you go um film
Friday as briay pointed out it's film
Friday um I do feel like to the previous
question whatever business we would run
together also feels like it would be a
reality show yeah somebody's like
amusement park that's a reality show we
run a cruise ship that's a reality show
we have a dry cleaner that's a reality
show those cats make that's a reliable
business right there people are always
getting their [__]
dirty I wanted to see if there's
something that we could do that we had
no idea how to do but we just got
plopped in it and also just like given
our
having lived in Los Angeles for a very
long time I thought it would be fun if
we started a NASCAR
team and the three of us were in charge
of growing a NASCAR team from like a
tiny little like building the car and
finding the driver and and and it would
be a complete reality show and how
awesome would that be like we'd be like
the Ted lasso of NASA of NASCAR can I
you know can I drive because I think I'm
a really good driver why not you are the
most offensive driver I
know like let him keep going left and
run into people if he has to I I I would
enjoy that very much and plus I think
people would be thrilled at like that
[__] he could die at any minute oh
[__] but like don't in for that somebody
calls it uh John Elrod in chat says days
of
blunder
[Music]
oh all right third question answer
answer we this question three uh in
honor of kev's KFI Gig if you could pair
two comic book oh this is from Mike's
story if you could pair two comic book
characters to have their own own morning
radio show who would it be he would love
to see Deadpool and plasticman in the
morning or here that's it those are two
great polls so for Saturday morning
cartoon well no for Saturday morning
radio like a radio show like you're
driving to work who's your morning drive
on AM radio yeah AM
radio who am I
doing comic book characters Batman's
been done a bunch now in like audible
[Music]
form um I would happily do I would
happily do the characters I've been
involved with in comics so I would do a
daredevil I would do a green arrow um I
would like to do the question although
the
question is very I mean look every comic
book is very visually oriented but the
question is you know [__] that's a
real visual gag so I don't know if that
comes through on a radio program I guess
it could but um yeah I'm Daredevil and
green arrow oh my God green arrow man I
could be doing not only just the voices
I could be doing like like that's an
arrow that kind of
[__] like the human
beatbox
nice uh what about
you
um I mean I I I kind of love the idea of
like a rocket and Groot
show um where Groot is just like the
[__] he's the entirety of the
wackpack and it's always just I am Groot
is the punch line to every joke but I
think rocket is a really interesting um
Talk Show
personality um Guy Gardner would be
fun uh Ted cord would be
fun
um yeah yeah yeah that's where I go I
think I go like Rocket and Groot I think
Rocket and Groot would be a hey the
name's just beg to be in the [__]
whackpack for somebody it's a rocket and
Groot hour here on the K9 1995 a like
just doing a [__] morning radio show
morning Zoo type show L the morning Zoo
the morning Zoo rocking groots morning
Zoo oh no it's Groot right so it's
rocking and groots morning
wood oh oh
nice we got it just a little bit dirty
I'm sure Disney will let us do it give
us our money
now yes we'll take our
checked what about you B man I think my
my head immediately goes to uh Wolverine
and Jean Gray just because I'd
love to have that like see how much of
that sexual tension comes through in the
mornings and then like every time Jean
is like I had a great weekend Logan uh
Scott and I and he just goes H H moving
on like I just want to see him get
frustrated every time she mentions her
her married life I have a pitch I would
like to do a morning radio show but not
with any of the
characters per se as the host but I
would play a radio host who lives in
either the Marvel or DC
Universe so you'd like you would do like
a two-hour morning radio show in either
Gotham Metropolis or just New York City
and as you're just you know talking
doing your morning superheroes are part
of your world anyway you have to [__]
talk about them so you could pull off a
pretty why are I giving this idea away
this is I know a great
idea you didn't hear
anything the am Genie was never here
that's that's something we could there
you go that's what we could all do
together the fake [__] morning radio
show that's set in the world of [__]
Marvel or DC or [__] or or how about
we don't have to limit it we could
literally do one for every universe so
we could do one for the Sin City
Universe we could do one for the [__]
you know uh uh Magnus Dr robot Magnus
fighter Universe uh Astro City we could
do Astro City we could do Harry Potter
you know hey man you're listening radio
muggle [__] welcome to copyright
infringement the morning show [__]
podcast you can talk for a free [__]
show come on man this a good idea right
here I could this [__] writes itself
Ryan Landis just wrote weather report it
looks like Mr free is iced over Gotham
again like [__] like that let's do
it the helicopter pilot like let's go to
the chopper 7even to see with bman
what's going on up there and be like
you'll never believe it The Incredibles
have saved the city
again um Brent a of grou has asked would
it be scripted or adliv I personally
hate when things become a job or more
work so I would vote for
adlet yeah I think it's one of those
like you have a general framework of
like all right well today we're going to
do [__] galatis is here and so it's
like we're talking about [__] what's
on the horizon over there it's I don't
know look galatis galatis what's it like
whatever that is but yeah I don't think
we need to be like reading scripts andit
[__] and we can have obscure guests man
like you could pick like a classic
[__] title and pick somebody who's in
two panels who interacts with the
[__] hero and be like we're talking
to you know [__] this person who met
Captain America uh hey man what was that
like and he tells a story that we know
from the comic and
[__] did you believe he's an [__] he
called me the n-word and he didn't even
know it was
bad oh no oh you're Captain America man
like he woke up from
1944 we're like we didn't feel the same
way about that word is a white dude in
Brooklyn in 1944 they're not gonna let
us do the show Mark we gota we got to
make it fun for people would you believe
there's a negro in charge of
Shield
happen Steve aspect to the whole thing
as well Steve that's not no Steve keep
it we talked about this Steve
um think about it dude we could have
guests you could have like you know F
even without going like ladies and
gentlemen Thanos is here just side car
foggy
Nelson you know what I'm saying like
maybe that's not sexy but it's like he's
real he's in universe and he would have
a
persective here's the hot dog guy set up
outside the Daily Bugle what can you
tell us about J Joon or
Jameson he likes it with everything and
he can be like look I don't know [__]
about J J Joe James is an [__] but
you know who rocks Spider-Man because he
[__] takes a hot dog with his web
makes it himself and then webs me back
$4 and the hot dog only cost 350 and and
I
exactly and I keep leaving all these
[__] quarters for him to web the
change back and he never
does basically I've got $300 in tips
from [__] Spider-Man that he pays his
[__] bills now Daredevil takes and
never gives
back yeah maybe he doesn't know what
numbers are on the bills I'm not really
sure is it a one is it a 20 we're always
going to get something different from
that guy super Shaun 064 said Ashley
Johnson as the waitress in The Avengers
being interviewed yes exactly that kind
of thing oh my God I love this idea
we're here with the owner of the
schwarma restaurant on 53rd in Broadway
tell us I mean your shop almost got
after after the attack after the attack
on New
York um your your your restaurant was
destroyed but in the aftermath something
special happened didn't
it yes Thor broke the rest of the
restaurant yeah Thor broke my toilet he
can
ship I wasn't worthy enough to pick it
up so it broke the
toilet if only he had a
tushy nice tushy.com folks lot tushi.com
to get your own tushy [__] stick it
on your toilet seat and clean your
[__] with water
hot.com um I look I love that two
questions dub tailed into one another
because we were like I don't know theme
park I don't know this I don't know that
this is our real estate making a goddamn
fake Morning Show in every fictional
Universe we only have to do like 10
episodes for the first season and if
people like it we come come back and do
more but think about it you do [__]
Star Trek universe Star Wars
Universe Harry Potter is previously
mentioned [__] we could do Brony
radio like one episode set in each
[__] reality that'd be dope man and
we're always the same broadcasters like
hey man you're listening to [__] you
know DJ and the squirrel or
whatever but castling McCormick um and
it's like a joke that we keep getting
fired and we get new jobs and like this
one's going to be a lot [__] safer um
welcome to Goth City kids I'm
[__] we're in a different Market
what's this Market say we're in the big
time you guys goam just pointed out we
could do it in in Masters of the
Universe as
well you could do one in Back to the
Future like something happen to the twin
Pond's mall last night that we should
probably
talk does anyone remember this being the
Lone Pine
Mall what if we just showed up on like
Friday to the radio the AM radio show
and just did it and like didn't say
anything done and done if if next time
like [__] they give me like hey man
can you want to take over two days I'm G
be like yeah but one of those days we
are gonna every drop every radio break
let's say it's a four hour show right
four hours so every hour is going to be
a different [__] reality like we're
broadcasting live from [__] you know
uh Bedrock ladies and gentle you know oh
God who would [__] number one
everyone on talk radio would be baffled
on AM radio listening be like what did
they say radio Bedrock like what they
acting like Fred Flintstone's
real I mean there's going to be like
seven very confused people in the
world the retire IR homes are going to
be like I knew it was real I grew up
watching Fred and Wilma I knew they were
real we're going to get rich off AM
radio you are this is the idea yeah like
we're gonna do it for free until
somebody pays us and nobody's
gonna nobody else can do this copyright
[__] Kev Mark and JC this our
idea I love it I thought I was [__] I
felt like Mark Bernardin for a second
there man I was like giving away a good
idea and then realizing it halfway
through going shut up and then you
didn't you didn't shut up you kept on
going Kevin I workshopped it we blue
skyed it in front of everybody there you
go that's the process and now it's a
matter of public record too so if
anybody steals this [__]
idea we did it first we did it first is
that all we got I mean I think the keg
is empty truly is man we we're we're now
just sucking gas
kids um do you have a good time I know I
[__] did [__] out you know when
you're out you know where you're going
to have a good time where else you're
gonna have a good time Ides of Mark SM
Cinemas March 15 starting with a live
Fat Man on
Batman uh and Then followed by uh ver a
movie that is is when it pours it
rains and it's not cocktail
um
uh come see the odds of Mark come see us
through fat man Beyond Live uh or come
see us through fat man beyond live on a
boat February we're on a boat
[__] on a boat Cru a skew kids
it's coming your way you can't stop it
it's going from [__] Miami to the
Bahamas then back to Miami happens
February 23rd to the 26 tickets at uh
cruises.com
um oh heavens uh what about uh what
about chronicon ladies and gentlemen the
just announced chronicon that's coming
to
Chicago October 11th through the 13 2024
man the very first in real life
chronicon get your tickets now go to
chronicon for
real.com man we're gonna announce all
the guests and schedule I bet you I
wouldn't be surprised if Mark Bernard
showed up wouldn't be surprised we were
doing fat men Beyond there as well
neither would I uh SM Castle Cinemas is
where you're going to see fat man beyond
uh Chicago is where you're going to see
chronicon and uh what else I I guess
that's it right oh oh look at that JC
put up uh the vulgarthon poster let me
tell you a quick little story about
vulon so you know we've been doing
vulgarthon for years we started back in
1998 uh this is the first time we're
ever doing it at SM castle cemas and so
we did a soft opening for vulgarthon I
didn't promote it I didn't put up on
Twitter I didn't put up on Instagram and
quietly sold that sold it
out like 230 people bought tickets to a
$69 event that is basically every VSC
movie in a row from 9ine o'clock in the
morning till 1 in the morning on
Saturday August 3rd the day after my
birthday um Clarks M rats Chasing Amy
Dogma Jane Silent Bob Strike Back Clerks
2 Jane Sil Bob reboot Clerk's 3 eight
[__] V Universe movies back to back
to back to back um and it's sold out but
we own a multilex so we just put another
screen on sale so the first theater one
starts at 900 am theater 2 will begin at
10: a.m. the program so tickets sell
right now for theater 2 man scap them up
before they're gone the first theater is
a 230 cater the second theater uh that
we're selling is
170 Cedar so those tickets are going to
go fast I think we've already sold 50 of
them and this is the first time I'm
publicly referencing this um and and I
haven't put it up on my socials yet but
I was so delighted that we sold out of a
[__] entire event and I didn't
promote it normally I'm the one that's
like hey did you buy a ticket hey did
you buy a ticket so vulgarthon is gonna
be [__] fun man and and now I'm like
there's you know seven months till the
event happens I have the secret dream
that we can fill all five theaters at
vulgarthon nice dagger them each by an
hour so the last one starts the first
one starts at 9ine so it's 9 10 11 12
one like the the last one would start at
two o'clock and go till like four in the
morning and [__] um but anyway tickets
right now at smodcastle cinemas.com come
spend a day with us in New Jersey if you
make it to the end I stole the idea that
Mark told me about when he did the
Marvel Marathon if you made it to the
end they gave you a [__] like a
medallion or something y so we're going
to do a challenge coin like like these
like if you're if you if you're a member
of that Kevin Smith Club we've been
doing like challenge coins this one's
kevolution series all different looks of
me and stuff Through the Ages um we're
gonna do one of these if you make it to
the end amazing you're you're going to
walk away with [__] your own CH SM
Castle Cinemas vulgar Thon challenge
Clin so tickets on sale right now it's
monast cinemas.com thank you JC I
completely forgot that I'd sent him the
artwork for that as
well um look at that don't forget mass
of the universe happening right now now
that we're done go to Netflix and watch
it people seem to be having a very good
time with it and I'm so delighted by
that thank you we're never gonna get to
mass Universe reparations unless you
watch all of season two I'm totally
telling Teddy Rob title for
three um kids do you have a good time
well that's because uh JC bman himself
got us to your homes give it up for
bman who like will Wilkins the Unseen
hero of all this is the person who makes
sure we get to you bman makes sure we
get online will Wilkins makees sure you
see us on YouTube on Facebook on
anywhere that you could [__] watch
this
show um but there is no show without the
guy in the other
box I'm in the litter box he's in the
other the night country give it up for
uh you are is that where you are I guess
it is that's where I am I'm in the
Borealis night Borealis behind you uh
give it up for marvelous Mark Bernardin
ladies and gentlemen thank you sir uh
there it is kids there's about almost
three hours of fat man beyond for you to
[__] play around with what time do we
start uh about
8:10
yeah yeah so two and a half hours was a
pretty long show we went for it yeah you
got some news you're up to date you know
everything about the culture of the pops
ladies and gentlemen thanks for hanging
out with us for fat man beyond uh I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernard tune in
next time ladies and gentlemen same fat
time kids same fat Channel smodcast.com
or youtube.com Kevin Smith Double Jeff's
kiss kids
[Music]
this is theat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask keev anything
every Saga has a 10-year anniversary
ladies and gentlemen and this is what
happens with Jay and S Bob get old up
Kevin Smith
J